[Music]
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet
David vales contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we get no value to haters
how run homie look what I become I'm I'm
the
one look for those of you guys joining
us on Saturday morning okay 9:00 a.m.
6:00 a.m. specific Standard Time to hear
two Legends at the same time in one
podcast podcast number 312 with Tim p
and Jimmy dor in the house uh we're
going to have a very unique show we got
a lot of things to cover today uh we had
a great event with you last night your
event in Miami that was fantastic with
yourself Matt Gates uh o'keef Luke and
uh my uh uh little Pharma guy big
far who is funny as hell yeah he's funny
as hell we had a good time but uh yeah
it was fantastic yesterday just listen
to everybody the exchange I thought it
was a great event I think you stole the
show you had that great uh uh call
speech about you know you said you don't
pray for tolerance anymore you have to
hope all that stuff the crowd went nuts
they all stood up gave you standing
ovation big Standing Ovation pbd
Standing Ovation at a podcast is pretty
freaking impressive Tim congrats man the
event was awesome and just on a personal
note your boys Luke Ian Sheamus even
awesome crew you got man congratulations
oh yeah I mean and you know Sheamus
hosts Freedom Tunes it's he he produces
that's his own show Luke of course of we
are change so they they're running their
own business as well to be able to have
them come down is an honor honor and a
privilege as well as you uh Patrick it
was just a dream come true man and talk
about the timing we booked this uh uh
we've been working on it for a year and
so when this past week happened with
Matt Gates fighting in Congress and then
I'm looking at the calendar I'm like we
are very lucky we have mat Gates
sometimes looking down
yeah that was great Jimmy how you been
Jimmy Matt Gates is a terrorist and he's
really creating chaos and I don't know
why he doesn't follow the Norms this is
I'm really offended and you know the
Democrats don't have these kind of
problems they all fall in line in lock
Steep and they're proud of it right
fiser you know they're they're real nice
he should just be nice to the lobbyists
and the pharmaceutical companies I
thought he was way more likable than the
media portrays him he was actually
paying he actually went to college with
me right around the same time we did the
there but don't congratulations on
Landing that right at the theend of it
didn't they go after so they went after
Matt Gates like a year or two ago
because they knew they couldn't control
him and they tried to pin him out at
being a pedophile and and uh that's
that's the game they did jul niss
they're doing it to Rusty Rockets
they're doing it to they did it to like
oh that's right they already tried to do
that to him and it's because they knew
they couldn't control him and so I loved
when he gave that speech on the floor
talking about I I'm going to this body
is bought and by big donor money and
they booed him only place in the world
that would get a boo is in Congress when
you're saying that the government's
bought by Big Money donors and anywhere
else in the world they would cheer him
but inside Congress that's how corrupted
Boo and he said go ahead and boo because
I'll be raising more money through small
dollar donations and I'm going to go
right to the people we talked about that
last night as well he brought that up by
the way we got a lot of things to cover
okay a lot of things to cover we got the
Israel Palestine issue that just took
place we'll talk about that want to get
your thoughts on that uh we got a talk
about Matt Gates McCarthy we'll get into
that as well Donald Trump followers
being targeted by the FBI 2024 election
story just came out Hillary Clinton
talking about there needs to be a formal
deprogramming of the Trump cult members
we'll show that clip and react to it
Ronda Sanz Jabs at Trump says he would
be a lame duck president if elected
Trump fears be poisoned using individual
many catchup battles uh polls about RFK
curious to know if RFK Junior's
independent run could pull from Trump or
from Biden that's a conversation a lot
of people are having Biden
Administration Jimmy you you'll be very
impressed with this one here they have
decided to build a wall which is such an
honorable thing to do racist some racist
well I hope they break all the
environmental rules that they set up to
do it yeah which that's the story by the
way so then we'll talk about Ukraine
curious to know what your thoughts are
today with Ukraine especially story that
came out saying few Americans support
arming Ukraine a poll that came out
diversity numbers amongst delegates
trigger alarm at d and C
meetings and then we'll talk about ahead
of 2024 felons are fighting to regain
the right to vote I don't know if this
is felons I don't know if it's a party
trying to get felons to get the right to
vote but either way we'll talk about it
Putin is saying America always needs an
enemy he's talking nuclear he's talking
big game we'll play a clip react to that
your boss might just give you a raise
for showing up to the office bosses are
given raises if you work from office I
was here early I was here early by
that's why you got aace you got aace
let's go baby and then Adidas Kanye West
didn't mean the anti-semitic remark
which I definitely want to get your
thoughts on but I say we start off I say
we start off with Israel and Palestine I
mean this literally just happened how
much are you following the story with
what happened not at all okay are you
Jimmy at all following it no I haven't
okay so this we woke up to it and this
happened so why don't we read Rob if you
got one of the stories or video clips to
show uh Israel says it's at war after
surprise attack from Gaza uh Netanyahu
even said we're at War uh did you say
last week Hamas attacked Israel 200
Israelis uh Hamas is claiming that last
week alone 200 Palestinians were killed
and this is this is one of their their
payback attacks but they planed on it's
a holiday this is a it's a Jewish
holiday today isn't it Adam well here's
what's going on uh last week was yumore
which is the holiest day um on the
Jewish calendar it's the day of
atonement and this attack took Place
talk about symbolism on the 50th day of
the anniversary of the uh yum kipor War
which was in 1973 so um do you want to
get into some of the details go ahead
well uh coinciding sort of with all this
I don't know how closely you guys pay
attention to Israeli politics it's not
exactly I wake up I'm reading Israeli
politics but I was just there um I took
my mom for her first time in 30 years
and um she lived on a kibutz back in the
day I I went for a wedding and um you
saw the protests that were going on
against BB Netanyahu okay Benjamin is
the longest standing prime minister in
Israeli history I think this is his 16th
year his fifth term it started in early
2000 or late 90s ear he's been around
forever but the whole premise with him
right now um is he's sort of the he runs
the lud party sort of the Trump of
Israel basically he's sort of the the
the rightwing there and um he's been you
know accusations of uh fraud and
embezzlement what have you you know
whether that's right or wrong that's the
sort of what going on but uh where he's
come under heat lately is because he's
basically trying to reform the Supreme
Court because he feels they're too
liberal so the platform that he's been
running on is that he's the guy that's
going to make Israel safe okay there's
no doubt the whether you're on left and
right because it's you go to Tel Aviv
it's very very left like LGBT Pride all
that you go to Jerusalem and it's I mean
as conservative as it gets yeah so he's
trying to reform the um Kess the Supreme
Court and the the parliament over there
because he feels they've gone too
liberal but uh he's been running on the
platform that he's the guy that's going
to keep Israel safe uh from what I'm
hearing because I text my buddy who I
was at um at his wedding he's like yeah
this is I thought this would basically
make citizens coales like sort of how
like 9/11 happened here and like didn't
matter if you were a Republican or
Democrat I said what's your take on this
and he's not a BB Netanyahu fan I said
will this make you appreciate him more
right he goes no it's the exact opposite
cuz the entire platform he ran on was
he's the guy that's going to keep Israel
safe so what you're kind of sort of
hearing on the ground is what happened
BB what's going on this is not a good
look for the IDF it's not a good look
for Mad who's the intelligence agency
and basically the story is this was sort
of a coordinated sneak attack they it
was Land Air
seers Boats
Rockets who has officially declared war
on just to be clear Hamas now how
familiar are you guys with the concept
of Hamas so Hamas is a militant uh
terrorist organization that the US
government has labeled terrorist they
sort of azb from Iran and they were
founded I believe in 1987 with the basic
premise that they will never ever ever
recognize the state of Israel and um
they came from the origins I believe of
the Muslim Brotherhood which spouted out
of um Egypt I want to say and they
reject all peace agreements whatsoever
so now I think 5,000 Rockets have been
fired to Israel there's been uh 500 in
40 dead um you know the Iron Dome that
Israel has that us has sort of funded as
as of when as of that is as of this
morning wow yeah oh no it's crazy 5,000
imagine so I text my buddy just to kind
of put it into context I text my buddy I
said how you doing over there he goes I
woke up to uh the sounds of sirens bombs
uh destruction I go how you doing he
goes you know what and this is sort of
like Israeli satire he goes uh I had a
taco party planned for today they ruined
Hamas ruined my freaking taco party T me
it's like how are you going to ruin my
party but um so funny the the um the the
bigger thing that I think that we should
understand here as far as Israel goes
and US goes because if you're in the
United States you're like all right how
does this affect me what BB Netanyahu
has done is sort of recognized I'm never
going to make peace with these guys you
know it started with the Oslo Accords
with um yitzak Rabin and yaser arat
under Clinton in '93 and they've been
trying to make peace with these guys
forever Hamas does not want peace think
you might saying well who's Hamas are
they the government well actually they
have a majority of parliament it'd be
like literally the equivalent of in the
United States KKK had more than 50%
representation in Congress which is
insane to me so the president mmud abah
he runs the
um Palestinian National Authority but
what BB has done and this is ultimately
my point is he said look I'm not going
to make friends with the 1% over here
what I'm going to do is open up
diplomatic and peace relationships with
the rest of the Middle East and that's
been his entire agenda so they've had
long-standing peace agreements with uh
Egypt with Jordan which are their
bordering neighbors but it since the
Abraham Accords which was under Trump in
20120 when he moved the
um the uh what' he move from uh the
embassy exactly to Jerusalem they've
made peace with the UAE with uh Bahrain
Morocco Sudan and now in in in the
middle of all this I don't know if you
saw that story Wall Street Journal Saudi
Arabia is in the in the in the final
endings of coming to a peace agreement
with Israel Saud okay and Saudi has said
they quote unquote are willing to raise
the oil output to basically appease the
Biden Administration uh to get this deal
done like Saudi wants to get this done
why because they want security they want
weapons they want intelligence you know
Israel you know love them or hate them
whatever you want to say to them they
have the right to defend themselves
that's the whole thing but they when you
talk about um the mad and the IDF when
you talk about intelligence talk about
tech you have this small little startup
company country uh that is was since
1948 and is an economic miracle
and what they're the ones that now the
rest of the Middle East is saying why
would we want to get make befriend
Palestinians and we should make uh peace
with Israel so uh the the the bottom
line is you I thought this would sort of
help BB but this might end up hurting
him and how it affects the United States
are all these peace agreements
specifically with Saudi Arabia Jimmy how
should the US react to this how should
the US how should Biden how should the
president of the United States react to
this you know I don't I'm not an expert
on Palestine Israel relations I don't
know how it's ever I don't think it's
ever going to be resolved I don't see
you know at first I thought a one state
solution was the best thing but that's
never and then I thought just two State
and so I really am not the guy to talk
to about this side but um I do know that
Israel has been bombing Syria uh and no
one gives a [__] and uh so they're just
allowed to do whatever they want I know
they have a nuke uh and so uh but it's
good to hear that that Saudi Arabia and
that they're starting to to make peace I
don't understand why the other Arab
countries uh and I need to explain to me
why they don't do something about
Palestine and why you know and the Gaza
St what what is their responsibility to
this the and I'm no Israeli Palestinian
expert but I've been there a bunch and I
know people and I have friends and this
is a this is you know Israel is the only
democracy in the Middle East it's not
even close and uh so you ask like who
are your allies pbd is coming out with a
book called choose your enemies wisely
look I I actually empathize with the
people of Gaza you know they have a term
called Jihad which is a holy war it's a
two-part War uh one is the spiritual
struggle internally and one is the
external struggle which literally means
killing people on behalf of your uh your
belief but if you talk about allies who
is Israel's allies okay we just said the
the peace treaties but United States
beyond that uh Hamas is a Sunni
organization okay uh but their allies
are
um Iran that's their major Ally with
Hezbollah and um the militants that's
going over there so Iran Syria um I
think I believe Kat um that's who they
are in bed with so you look at the rest
of the Middle East you know you're
you're familiar with Sunni Shiite Iran
uh the the the constant struggle with
Saudi Arabia um they they're picking
sides just like you think why why don't
Arabs all get along Sunni Shia like this
is a major thing for them uh and it goes
way deeper than anything we've ever
known here in America where where
Republicans and Democrats are constantly
fighting it's never been stopping Tim
you know I think the CH the challenge
for me obviously is I'm not hyperfocused
on Israel Palestine I think correct
everyone's saying the same thing but uh
the bigger picture going back uh like 10
years or so I remember when I think they
did what was it called protective Edge
I'm I'm not sure what the the campaign
was where it was described as many
people on the anti-war left as mowing
the lawn I think it's a phrase
attributed with what Israel does every
few years they go to war yeah it's 2014
there you go uh uh so they they called
that the Gaza war in 2014 protective
Edge that's right and uh uh it was
viewed and uh many journalists explained
to me that those and again I'm not an
expert on this they call it mowing the
lawn where every few years Israel is at
war with Gaza to decimate and destroy
their weapons their their supply Depots
and things like this but the big fear is
every time they do this it antagonizes
the Middle East and other countries that
are upset over what's going on in
Palestine and at the time there was
concern that if Iran begins supplying
War weapons or or UPS the ante in some
capacity one it could lead to just
obvious widespread destabilization of
the region which we're already you know
not happy about I think things have
improved with Abraham Accords and a lot
of these peace agreements my fear is
this could seek to dest that problem but
the bigger issue I see now especially
with Ukraine and Taiwan is you know we
can't handle any more conflict
escalating to this point if and and this
may be occurring because the US is
entering a new quag
for for what reason it's not been
Justified I have no idea what gas prom
gas monopolies cutting off Russia from
the Black Sea because we want to control
the price of gas or something like this
then you've got as we're hyperfocused in
Eastern Europe China's flying uh uh uh
what are they call sorties or whatever
over Taiwanese taiwan's air air defense
Zone and so I'm just sitting back like
either the media is just screaming in my
face at the top of their lungs to scare
me or we are we are experiencing way too
much International conflict and
destabilization and considering the
politics of the United States and what's
happening internationally with you know
this the the Civil conflict in the west
with what they call the far right across
Europe as well as the United States you
know people are calling it civil war in
World War II all bottled up into one the
last thing I need to do is wake up after
this beautiful Friday night party with
war is breaking out now in the Middle
East well I think Tim you make up a
great point this is the definition of
whack-a-mole you know you're focusing on
Ukraine oh oh what are we doing with
China and Taiwan oh look what's going
the war going on Israel so it begs the
question what is America's role in all
this are we the world's police do we get
involved do we get involved in proxy
wars it's it's problematic America so I
think the Palestine Israel is a
different conflict than all the other
conflicts right so Ukraine Russia China
these are all provoked by the United
States and we're uh you know what's
happening in in Ukraine is just a money
laundering operation and it's there so
that we could have more liquefied
natural gas from Western countries uh
sold to Europe and that's why we bombed
the northstream pipeline and uh you know
Joe Biden had predicted he would do it
in February right be he said if Putin
has tanks that go across into Ukraine
we're going to end the northstream
pipeline so that's what this was always
about and it was provoked uh we provoked
Putin to do that you know what's funny
is that everybody uh starts the story of
Ukraine with Putin's invas
but that and the way the way I tell it
it's like if Putin was standing at a bus
stop and there was an old lady in the
street and there was a bus coming right
for her and Putin pushed that lady down
on the sidewalk to get out of the bus
the mainstream media starts that story
Putin pushes old lady down and they they
leave out the beginning like no there
was a bus coming and he was trying to
save so they forget they leave out the
part then in 2014 the United States and
the CIA instituted a coup in Ukraine
with the right- ring Nazis and the
people in the eastern part of Ukraine
didn't want to go along with that coup
government and so they resisted it and
so that coup government the Nazis
started bombing the donbass there
actually was a peace agreement called
the Minsk Accords guess who broke that
Ukraine it wasn't Russia it wasn't Putin
it wasn't the people of the dbat so
finally after eight years of shelling
and two-piece agreements that were
broken uh and the threat of putting uh
Ukraine into NATO and all uh Putin said
hey if you just promis me you won't put
him in Ukraine I won't invade they
wouldn't do that why because they wanted
this to happen happened because they
they when they ended Afghanistan they
needed a new war for the
military-industrial complex was when
people were giving Biden all that credit
for ending Afghanistan even though he
did it horribly people were still giving
him credit I was like well let's wait
and see what he's going to do with that
money that they've been spending in
Afghanistan because I bet they have
another War up there sleeping son of a
[__] they did it was Ukraine which
they've been ramping up for for at least
eight years and they've admitted that
they've been doing this and ramping up
and provoking this and anybody who knows
anything about it this was completely
100% provoked they wanted this to happen
they ran up the bombing in February so
Putin would invade they doubled it so
that's what's happening and the same
thing and if you think Russia and China
we have 800 military bases around the
world we just built three more in the
Philippines to get ready for this uh
saber rattling with China and they just
built a military base in Syria as they
call Putin a thug and a gangster for
doing what he's doing in Ukraine we are
occupying a country right next door a
third of it which third the oil part and
we just built a military base there and
that's why they hate Trump cuz he told
the truth about it when they asked him
hey why are you leaving troops there and
he said for the oil it's our oil and
they can't have he told the truth about
our foreign policy and that's why they
got to get rid of them yeah quick
response to that you're absolutely right
the the Ukraine situation has been a
marketing campaign to basically most
Americans could not pick out Ukraine on
a map that's right of just Ukraine so uh
I I think the uh what's going on in
Israel and Palestine the US does not
need to get involved in that they might
fund an operation they might be involved
they're not going to have boots on the
ground they're not getting involved in
that whatsoever and the you've seen the
numbers how Americans especially even
Democrats have plummeted for their
approval of what's going on in Ukraine
do we have those numbers um but uh in
the biggest problem in Adam what do you
what do you getting to cuz I'm trying to
read this poll here what are you getting
to no is that we're America should not
focus necessar let read this focus on
ukra going back on what you were talking
about ukrainians few Americans support
arming Ukraine poll this is the hill a
Reuters poll uh survey a significant
drop in supporting Americans for sending
arms to Ukraine with only 41% of
respondents favoring such action in
October down from 65% in June of 2023
that's a big drop by the way 24% support
for sending arms to Ukraine has declined
across political parties Democratic
support dropped from
81% to 52% and Republican support
dropped from 56 to 35 independent
support went from 57 to 44 the survey
also indicates that support for sending
financial aid to Ukraine is even lower
with 37% of respondents favoring it an
October survey the decline in support
comes amidst debates over Government
funding and evolving dynamics of 2024
GOP Presidential primary you know I I we
had this really extended media uh cycle
about the pipes in Flint Michigan and
then it expanded after the Flint
Michigan pipes the kids are getting sick
there's Legionnaire disease the water
was bad then we learn it's bad in Newark
then we learn it's bad in Pittsburgh and
and all of these Democrats are coming
out saying we must get funding to fix
this and now all these people are saying
we must give this money to Ukraine so we
can have war and I said I have a
compromise how about we fix all the
pipes in Pittsburgh New York Flint
apparently is doing better but let's
build American infrastructure Let's help
the poor in our cities let's whatever
education program whatever Healthcare
program hey how about the 250 billion or
whatever goes here but the weirdest
thing to me is to see young leftists on
social media being like we have to stand
with Ukraine I'm like why and you know
so think the hypocrisy right there for
me and and the people I know they're
asking themselves why did we spend all
this money over there when we had a
decade of of of water problems in in our
own country but more importantly when I
pulled up the battle map a couple weeks
ago of Ukraine I was shocked because I
wasn't tracking the on the ground stuff
with Ukraine as much I was shocked to
discover that Russia won because they've
been telling us over and over and over
again that we've been win that we we're
winning Russia's decimated they're
conscripting people they're panic and
there these videos of like the Ukrainian
Soldier flicking the cigarette and being
like ukra whatever and then I you pulled
the battle map and you're like wait so
Russia secured the entire donbass Land
Bridge from from the donbass the
landbridge into Crimea which was their
which was their stated goal so so I feel
like every story coming out saying we
are winning and let's go and I'm like
Russia wanted to control access to
Crimea it's their access to the
Mediterranean through the Black Sea
through the BOS forus into the
Mediterranean because I want to that's
how they they ship a lot of their oil
and gas
and what what the threat was to them was
that if Ukraine joins nato in the EU it
cuts off Crimea well first of all before
all this in 2014 before Crimea was
basically taken by Russia and bet a
referendum call whatever you want the
the the the threat Russia's facing is we
have the sast sasao base we transport a
lot of our energy through this through
through here if Ukraine falls to the EU
and NATO we lose access to the
Mediterranean we can't allow that so
first thing they do they walk out of
their naval base in sasto and say we're
already here actually quote unquote
referendum take it with the expansion of
the war they needed to secure access
into Crimea outside of just the the
actual bridge over water which we saw
bombed not that long ago now I'm looking
at this map and we have it right here
wow Russia Russia's secured land access
into Crimea which was their their my my
understanding was their stated goal
they're pushing pass towards Odessa now
which is insane and when I talk to you
know neocon types
proar establishment Types on the left or
liberal Democrat whatever you want to
call it they keep saying no uh Vladimir
Putin wants Poland no no Vladimir Putin
and I was like what's what strategic
value does Vladimir Putin have right now
economically look you want to make the
argument that Putin's 20 year plan is to
invade Poland fine but right now what
we're dealing with this makes total
sense in terms of bringing oil into the
Mediterranean competing with on on the
oil market and you telling me that
Vladimir Putin is a comic book villain
who wants to take over the world means
nothing it says nothing about his
strategy nothing about where he's
placing his troops when I look at this
I'm like oh right he wants the
landbridge into Crimea to secure it so
that you can't kick him out he's gotten
it that seems like a military goal it
seems like Ukraine's lost this one and
we're dumping money down the toilet
question I got for you Jimmy is why why
is it because no matter where you went
your Democrats all had the Ukrainian
flag Instagram Facebook Twitter the
other day we're in New York where
Yankees game gets canceled we go to uh
bowling event the UN is in New York Bill
Clinton shows up with his uh ukra we're
talking to him he's got the Ukraine pin
on right instead of the red white and
blue but why are why are Democrats now
dropping this is not like a small
Difference by the way they went from
81 to 52 Republicans 56 to 35
Independents 5 this is not a small
number why do you think now people are
saying guys we got to stop I think
because they're starting to hear
counternarratives be like they're
they're hearing from people like Tucker
Carlson my show Rusty Rockets all and so
it's starting to seep in the truth about
what's going on over there and they see
how they don't give a [__] about Amer so
this I remember I had Marian Williamson
on my show a month or two ago and she's
Pro Ukraine war and funding it and I was
like why do you think that they're doing
that she's like well we're trying to
help the people of Ukraine I go if you
think this is about helping people don't
you think we'd start helping people here
in America First is what Tim just said
minutes ago that why wouldn't we start
here if we really of course they don't
care about people they don't even take
care of the people in the Maui right now
they nothing they don't give a [__]
about them they got people living under
every bridge nobody cares it's not about
the people they would even give us
healthc care still people still go
bankrupt when they get sick in America
the only Western Country that happens in
so this is all about money laundering
and why is the numbers going down I
think because people are starting to
realize this is stupid and all the money
we sent they're starting to get another
counternarrative Bobby Kennedy's out
there talking about it and it's getting
talked about on Joe Rogan and so uh
those are that's the biggest platform in
the world right so people are starting
to hear a counter narrative before and
now they're starting to get caught up to
what the game is happening that's what I
think's happening so let me let me
follow up on that so you saw a GOP
debate the second one that took place
right and whether it was I did not oh
you didn't see it okay so Nikki Haley
Tim Scott a lot of them are still Pro
funding the Ukrainian War but if their
campaign manager or their helpers are
sitting there saying guys 81 to 50 2 56
to 35 57 to 44 this is not a winning
like what are you doing the American
people are sick of the spending why are
they still sticking to their position to
defend that because they're sticking to
their their loyalty isn't to the
American people their loyalty is to
their donors and their donor class wants
this right so the donor class is Wall
Street the fossil fuel companies and the
military-industrial complex and they
want this and that's that and they don't
serve the people and that's what Matt
Gates is talking about and and that's
why they're booing him and in Congress
because he's talking about giving the
Congress back to the people and they
can't have that because they want it to
be H by the donor class which it is and
and look how brilliant it is though
Jimmy like first thing like remember
when it came out P like remember that
first six months Ukraine everybody had
the flag everybody had it on Instagram
just like when BLM everybody put that
black square like it did [__] like that
black Square did anything but then Pat
look look look at their their Brilliance
Jimmy they do all that they do all that
then it gets to the point where the word
is out but now it's like it's too late
we already gave the money we already
embedded what are you going do just like
the Border look at the border for for
almost four years mayorcas all these
[__] are like no no it's not a
crisis not now now they're like yeah
it's time to build a wall too late
there's seven [__] million people
here sorry for my language seven million
and the but the reason for it is because
now you got Democrats in these big
cities complaining yep so they're their
their their party members are saying hey
we're dealing with a problem it's going
to cost us votes and they're like okay
we'll build the wall now yeah but maybe
this war in Ukraine has woken up the
people that maybe never woke up about
that stuff just sort of just operated on
a on a following I wouldn't be surprised
if zinski is on a plane right now to go
to the White House to be like Hey listen
don't do nothing Israel don't get
involved that's my M don't help them at
all I think to Tim's point this is my
question for Tim this is why I I think
you made such a great point you know the
whole America First agenda when you
heard that first from Trump there's a
lot of people that basically labeled
that racist America first [__] the rest
of the world basically hold on what hold
on what's going on here but you poly
gave the example of things like Flint or
uh in um Pennsylvania whatever these
things and now Americans are realizing
hold on I I was fed you know this
Ukraine thing for 6 12 18 months what's
going on here in FL but here's my
question to you you know when we asked
you uh about you know your knowledge of
Israel you're like like I don't follow
this much dude you just like almost like
you you are like a battlefield General
in Ukraine you you you know this Inside
Out is this something that you've been
following for 18 months or to be fair
years I was there just before the coup
happened in 2014 or 20 so I was I went
there in 2013 I produced a couple
documentaries for vice breaking down was
going on and I talked to a lot of people
there I I I I actually got to I wasn't
there when they toppled the statue of
Lenin but I got there literally right
afterwards and saw the statue ripped
down and people were smashing it with
hammers it was a crazy sight to see so
uh I have friends there I the country is
fantastic the food's great the people
are awesome and it it was it was a a
really amazing trip for me when I was
down there from 2013 in 2014 and then uh
watching how it has devolved since then
I think you know I don't know what the
intention was what what uh uh I suppose
I what the United States machine was
hoping to get out of coverage from
something like me from someone like me
or whatever all that Ed up happening was
I I I despise the efforts of the West to
exacerbate this war more having been
there and met people there and I have
friends who are they fled the country
and and and and and for for what reason
this thing this goes back right I may
not be able to tell you about the inner
workings actually you know what I got to
stop I I actually probably do know a
decent amount about Ukraine considering
clear the barisma stuff uh considering
right all of this I'll give you I'll
give you the simple version I am but a
humble man who complains on the internet
I read news stories and I read reports I
read academic articles sometimes about
the region and uh I remember a lot of
these articles so my understanding of
what's happening there is I would just
say news curs
and there are individuals with
clearances and accesses they probably
know more than me but this goes back to
the cutter turkey pipeline I'm sure uh
you guys are familiar are you familiar
with this so the United States the West
wanted a pipeline from cter up through
Syria and turkey into Europe to displace
the gas prom gas Monopoly Syria said
explicitly we are allied with Russia we
will not allow you to do this in fact
they were going to counter this pipeline
by having Iran build a pipeline and run
that instead strengthening the the
Eastern uh uh energy uh energy Monopoly
whatever you want to call it it was
explicitly reported I'm I'm amazed this
is in the guardian that in 2009 the CIA
said we will destroy Syria we will
overthrow them lucky lucky for us a few
years later a civil war breaks out we're
on the side of of of the rebels because
this is a country that said we will not
allow you to build a pipeline all of
this then connects into you have the gas
prom gas Monopoly which its pipeline
runs through Ukraine all of a sudden
this this Energy company pops up in
Ukraine where we've got a former CIA
director Hunter Biden on the board and
now everything we're learning with the
investigation into the bidens into
Hunter Biden Hunter Deon Archer
testifying Hunter Biden calls DC and
says we need help Joe Biden then flies
out says fire the prosecutor you know I
I'll simplify this for you mola Levy the
founder of bman it's an energy company
we have massive interests in in building
these energy companies he is accused of
of corruption he's under investigation
by my by uh Victor shoken the prosecutor
in Ukraine he fle the country after his
assets are frozen Joe Biden comes in and
says oh the prosecutor's corrupt fire
him conveniently right after his son
calls DC saying I need help because
they're they're feeling this pressure
the the uh several months later shoken
finally resigns and guess what mesy
returns to the country now hold on I
thought he what what's what this this
guy is is accused of corruption but he
comes back Joe Biden says at the CFR
meeting that that we brought we got in
someone who was solid someone who was
solid someone who was solid cleared this
guy guess what when Donald Trump made
that phone call saying what's going on
with this homie fled the country again y
cuz he knew the investigations were back
on there is absolute corruption and the
the fascinating thing is that all of
this is in the media it's you see it
reported but my favorite example of how
the media is a is a spattering of CIA
FBI whatever you want to call it and
sometimes real journalists is just after
the 2016 election Politico reported that
Ukrainian officials interfere in the US
election to assist Hillary Clinton
Politico has this you can you can pull
this up then about a year or two later
Politico reported that very story they
reported was Russian disinformation
without retracting their own story this
has been happening
so I I could I could talk 50 billion
years about all this stuff but I think
my point you know what that that's the
thing people don't realize about Syria
which Bobby Kennedy was on to and that's
where I found out about that gas
pipeline was through Bobby Kennedy years
ago and 2017 I'm like why is there a a
war in why does the CIA want to
overthrow uh Assad and it turns out
that's why we got in bed with so right
now we're in bed with Nazis in Ukraine
legit Hitler Nazis and but in Syria we
were in bed with Al-Qaeda and elnusa and
the people and Isis are sworn enemies go
ahead just just to add the Canadian
Parliament gave a standing ovation to a
Nazi to a Nazi hit 98y old no background
check and so people don't realize that's
what all that Assad was and tulsy gabri
toldo up and stood up and told the truth
about that and that's why they had to uh
smear her as a Russian agent and all
that stuff because whoever tells the
truth about our foreign policy when the
game that's being played they
immediately get called an assadist or
you get called a Putin puppet or they
would call you a Saddam puppet or a
traitor to the country and they're doing
the same thing they're doing Iraq
they're doing it Libya they're doing in
Syria they're doing in Ukraine it's all
the same [__] and people don't wake up I
can't believe that people who saw them
do Iraq and then nobody really looked
into Libya and then they saw them do
Syria they got tricked into Syria again
and the same game in Ukraine I can't
believe they're falling for this over
and over you know here's what it is
here's what I'm noticing with the trend
that they're they're they come in saying
I think they will believe us for a
year and then that's all we need and
with a year we'll sell enough supplies
to make money and then all of a sudden
that 81 on Democrat support goes to 52
that's right Republican goes 5635 and
then independent goes 57 to 44 and by
far the best meme I've seen as a person
who's an entrepreneur I support small
business owners especially some of them
that want to work from home do something
part-time there isn't anybody that's
done a better job you know Rob if you
have this if you can pull this up please
I want to make sure the audience sees
this he is the goat of working from home
last month I made $40 billion working
from home learn how I think this is the
best transition for me to go into our
sponsor before we go to the next story
so funny today's sponsor is American
Hartford gold in 2022 central banks uh
central banks globally bought a
record-breaking 1136 tons of gold
there's a reason why they're doing that
according to the bank of international
settlement over 90% of central banks are
working on a cbdc and one of the ways
for you to Pro protect your Investments
I have owned physical gold for many many
years a small percentage but I always
buy gold and I set it aside American
hard for gold will ship the physical
gold to you or the silver directly to
your door you can also set up a 401k if
you call them up they'll show you how to
do it they'll show you how to protect
your savings and retirement accounts
they have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they have earned a five star
rating from thousands of reviews from A+
from Better Business Bureau tell them I
sent you and they'll give you up to
$5,000 free of silver on your first
order and call uh the link uh click on a
link below or call 8669 I think Jimmy's
about to call him right now Jimmy's got
to step out real quick 866939 6984 again
866939 6984 or text pbd to
65532 again text pbd to 65532 link will
be below okay so that's Ukraine let's
talk Matt gate so this
week all of a sudden I think we all
probably remember where we were at where
it said well um McCarthy is fired you're
like wait what is this a mistake like
this is this is not possible Right how
did this you know take place and a Matt
Gates is going out to calling out you
didn't keep your promise you didn't do
this you didn't do that yesterday I
asked him a question at your event that
you had in Miami I said when you were
doing that when you were pushing him did
you actually think it was going to be a
historic moment where this guy was going
to get fired or did you just think
you're going to scare him to have like a
you know publicity TV media reaction
kind of sharing your thoughts and he
gave his answer but from your
perspective you know what are your
thoughts about what happened is it a
good thing is it a bad thing unpack it
for us well this is exact Matt Gates is
doing the exact thing that I championed
two years ago when the Democrats had a
slim uh uh majority and I wanted the
progressives meaning the squad AOC and
those people to do what Matt Gates is
doing to the speaker they ran on doing
that to Nancy Pelosi and I said you
can't give your vote to her for speaker
unless you get some consessions from her
and they refused to do that and then and
half the people on the quote unquote
left turned on me and said that I was
doing something that was crazy this came
right from the DSA handbook this came
right from aoc's own campaign she was
like we got to have a vote on Medicare
for all so that was my ask my ask was
you don't vote for Nancy Pelosi unless
they give you a vote for Medicare for
all on the floor which is what Democrats
have been saying they wanted for two
decades if not longer since Nancy Pelosi
actually 1994 said she wanted that so
I'm like this is something everybody
agrees on on the left so let's they
wouldn't do it Matt Gates is not only
doing that he's not only challenging but
he's actually asking for reforms that
progressives should be cheering for he
wants to have single item bills voted on
you don't want to put school lunches in
with a border and Ukraine funding into
the same bill and that's garbage and he
wants that and he's going to he's to get
rid of McCarthy for that I got to tell
you it was really inspiring to listen to
his speeches and I realized that oh
that's why they've made him into be such
a monster and now they're literally
calling him a terrorist for doing that
and they're trying to make it look like
somehow he's a maniac and he's he the
the de the Republicans are out of
control and Chaos that's exactly what
someone's supposed to do and Matt Gates
I don't think he takes pack funding and
he raises most of his money through $200
or less donations and that's why he's
able to do this and it's like I don't
agree with probably most of his politics
but I agree with him doing this him
getting those reforms in the house
that's what lefties should be screaming
for and uh it's it's really great what
he's doing he's made a fan out of me
anyway and I love his anti-war stance
now the only thing I hope he doesn't
pivot and be pro-war on China but his
doing this to stop the funding for
Ukraine is a definite winner for him and
the American people are coming around to
his point of view so I think it's great
as a progressive and a lefty I wish that
the Democrats the progressives had half
the nuts that he does because he's
really oh it was just it was sweet I was
just pumping my fist and cheering this
guy on and and met Gates tweeted out
that he's willing to give some
concessions on the motion to vacate to
raise the threshold making it harder in
the future if they enact rana's reforms
so he's shouting out a Democrat Rana
says you can't you can't trade stocks in
Congress 12 12E term limit and no
lobbyist and pack money donations and uh
I'm I'm just I'm loving it I'm loving it
it's when you know driving in the car
Luke is uh I'm I'm in the passor seat
Luke's sitting in the back and he goes
Uh Kevin McCarthy's been removed and I
was like no no no no no hold on hold on
I pull up Twitter and I'm like no I
think I think they're saying they may
have the votes for now but it can still
reverse he's like no he's removed and
then I see the video and I press play
and it's like the A's have it the motion
to vacate and I was like I lost it I
just I'm like dead silent and then I'm I
just this is history the first speaker
to be removed and the issue is if the
Republicans made this big hubub about
2022 and winning a majority and once we
do we'll control the budget we'll do
these things but Kevin McCarthy is
unwilling to actually work with the
people who got him that majority and in
fact is just trying to work back room
deals particularly to get funding for
Ukraine then what's the point of of of
of of voting for these individuals if in
the end all Matt look I'm sure Matt
Gates and I will disagree on on a lot of
Po policy positions um like you know
Jimmy was mentioning but if the core of
his fight is reforms in Congress then I
think he's going to have 80% of the
country agreeing with him if they know
what's actually going on I'm gonna ask
this question and I want you to get the
question I asked last tonight I want to
ask it tonight and I want I want you to
give me a rebuttal gallipo comes out
right Republican Americans trust
Republicans and economy 53 to 39 highest
exchange you know difference between the
two ever okay they trust Republicans for
military they trust Republicans for
economy they trust Republicans for
almost everything right everything was
them Trust Group by the way we haven't
had this if you have the chart Rob to
pull it up if you've seen this it's not
something that's
normal you know for the longest time
they trust the Democrats if you look at
the blue and the red look at this
exchange on what's happened it's very
high and where we are today right it's
just a number we're not accustomed to
seeing and purple the people that no
difference no opinions going lower and
lower and lower which means people are
having more and more opinions of what
they want to do so yesterday there's
certain people that say Jimmy or Tim
they'll say well look at the Republican
party they're in shambles they're not
United this is why
Democrats will always win because no
matter what happens a Bernie Sanders
will set aside to protect and get behind
Joe Biden and he'll get up there and try
to convince the the elhan and and and
and you know AOC we got to support him
because we're going to get some things
done but no we wanted you Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren steps aside and Amy
steps aside and the great Pete Budd
steps aside and all these guys step
aside right and then good Republicans
man they can't even get and then even
some you know Trump say why can't these
guys all get along together so there is
different messaging from different
people open-ended question what do you
say to the people that are saying listen
Matt kind of just broke apart the
Republican party just because of eight
people were not happy with McCarthy
maybe maybe it is that right now what
mat Gates has done will will create the
image of disunity and scare the people
who finally turned around but I'll tell
you what I actually think I think the
reason you're seeing the Republican
party go up is because of Matt Gates
right because there have been for the
longest time for my entire life Congress
has been a waste of time and I didn't
even vote I voted for Obama I regretted
it because he blew up a bunch of kids
and then you get 2012 and 2016 I didn't
vote for anybody 2020 I turned around I
said okay maybe I want to start
supporting some of these guys 80
gallup's latest poll 82% disapproval in
Congress and Thomas Massie I think he's
a good guy but he stands up there and
give this passion impassion speech about
how if we vote to remove McCarthy this
institution will fail I bust out
laughing I'm like you think 82%
disapproval as an institution we want to
preserve I'm wondering if the reason
people are now actually saying I I trust
Republicans more is because they're
hearing something that actually aligns
more so with what they're looking for at
the very least if it is Matt Gates
saying I want reforms and no more
Politics as Usual no more revolving door
BS no more lobbyist money yeah okay I'm
behind Republicans for that if that's
what it is that being said Kevin
McCarthy actually creates problems in my
opinion for someone who wants to support
the Republican Party because as soon as
they get their majority what does he do
he starts playing politics as usual once
again the only thing keeping me
interested is Matt Gates yeah no I I
agree with that that this idea that
somehow you're supposed to have party
unity and that you know AOC was bragging
about it that oh the Democrats are
running like a well-oiled machine well
you're not supposed to you're you were
sent there to oppose the establishment
inside the Democratic party and of
course they're acting like that wasn't
what they were sent to do there but it
is what they're sent to do which is why
her approval ratings are in the [__]
too so uh they're not this is exactly
what they're supposed to be doing and
the only people who are
anti-war are people on the right in the
Republican party and as a lefty I got
nowhere to go it's just like I got so
it's it's again just reiterate it's
great what Matt Gates is doing so that's
why he's going to be slimed and smeared
in the corporate press up and down he's
going to be calleded everything from a
pedophile to a terrorist to a white
supremacist that's the game and so we
got to be aware of it and uh I I stand
in solidarity with his reforms in
Congress and I think most of the
American people they want to get pack
money out of there they want to have
single issue voting they want to have
more power to the to the members and
less power to the speaker and they want
to stop the funding of Ukraine and so it
doesn't matter if it's Nancy Pelosi or
Kevin McCarthy they're going to get that
funding for Ukraine they're going to get
the B bidding done of the B donor class
and so that's what Matt Gates is
standing up to and I thought that the
lefties would stand up to it Bernie
Sanders and and the squad and they
didn't in fact they all voted for the
largest upward transfer of wealth in
human history they all voted for funding
this Ukraine war instead of funding the
United States they rolled over
completely to be in the establishment
and that's what the Democratic party is
in lock step with the corporate media in
lock step with the donor class and the
establishment and I think people maybe
are waking up to it and that's why those
numbers are happening like that so I I
really can't say uh more about I always
thought this is going to happen from a
lefty and it's coming from mat Gates by
way as a lefty yourself what what is it
making you think about your your next
vote cuz you have a voice your show
people listen to what you have to say
and you're very passionate and you break
things down and you're a True Believer
you come across as a guy that's like
listen I'm a regular guy that just got a
lot of opinions and here's what I'm
going through what do you think what are
you grappling with yourself as your for
your vote in 2024 well uh I was um
thought I was going to support Cornell
West but I I'm not going to I can't see
that happening now he's in bed with the
same establishment people he's got Peter
da who's a cancer on the left in charge
of his campaign which is why he's
flailing and he just left the green
party so he's not going to get ballot
access so he's not really running for
president and that was clear to me when
he came on my show he didn't ask for my
vote he didn't ask for the votes of the
people who watch my show in fact he
looked like he was he just came on to
pick a fight with me and uh and he can't
stop saying that Joe Biden is the lesser
of two evil with Donald Trump so if you
say that you're undermining your own
Campaign which led me to believe he's
not really running so I am looking
forward to Bobby Kennedy uh declaring
his independent run because uh a lot of
the stuff he says is really important to
me like his uh his stance on coid
lockdowns authoritarianism and free
speech and you know he says if you don't
have free speech you don't have
democracy and that's true this idea that
voting for a Democrats though
democracy's on the ballot democracy
hasn't been on the ballot since 1980
okay your court your government was
taken from you by corporations decades
ago and when are people going to get
pissed off about that the guys on
January 6 weren't overthrowing the
government they were just protesting an
election just like the other half of the
country protest for four years and said
another country stole our election they
were saying it was stole by people and
they say you know oh they're trying to
over that's Cornell West came on my show
and he said oh they were trying to uh
overthrow the government and uh and
upset the peaceful transfer of power
really a bunch of Second Amendment gun
nuts wanted to go overthrow the
government and they forgot their guns
isn't that weird Oh I thought I'd
written it down mittens water I forgot
the
guns so it it's and now look what
they're doing so they're criminalizing
their political opponents that's what
they're doing to Trump they know he's
going to win the election so they're
going to make him a criminal and his
that's what January 6 was about that's
why there were so many FBI agents in the
crowd and they pushed those people into
their into the capital to so they can
set up this narrative and they could
make and now they're using the RICO
statute to prosecute Trump a RICO
statute which was uh invented to go
after the mafia not only are they using
it against their political
opponents Donald Trump they're also
using against the people who are prot
protesting stop cop City so it doesn't
matter if you're Donald Trump or if
you're a lefty uh protesting the
expansion of the police state they're
going to use the same Rico laws to go
after you because the establishment
criminalizes their opponents no matter
if he comes from the right or the left
and that's the game that's being played
and I'm trying to wake people up to that
and not that I'm going to vote for Trump
or I'm a trump fan but uh I can notice
what they're doing to him they're going
to do to anybody who stands up against
the establishment that's the game now
that's what they did to Lula that's what
they're did in Pakistan that's where D
that so there's you know the whole world
and I I hope you guys know that it's
only run by a handful of billionaires
right and there is no there is no
loyalty to a country the people who just
just like Ned batty said in that movie
network in 1974 there are no countries
there's only companies and the
international flow of dollars and you
can't upset that International flow of
dollars and if you do you have to atone
and that's where we're at these guys
don't care what happens to America
they'll fund a war everywhere in the
world before they fix the pipes or fix
the infrastructure or give health care
or education to anybody in the United
States and that's because we're run by
globalists like Bill Gates Bill Gates
who runs the wh right so he's the
biggest fun of the who goes China and
then Bill Gates they and then so I can't
go on YouTube and contradict The Who and
that's coming direct from Bill Gates so
he has a a monopoly on information flow
and uh that's the real game being played
right now it's not about countries it's
about a handful of billionaires at the
WF guys like Bill Gates Jeff Bezos
they're running everything and the
people in Congress are just doing the
bidding of those people and that's why
when Matt Gates stands up and says
something it's shakes the world and they
have to make it seem like it's bad
instead of what it actually is a real
Revolution that we need Jimmy I I I
always wonder why you hold back your
feelings why do you like you should let
a rip you know what I'm saying you
should let a rip go ahead you guys see
you see what they're doing to Trump in
New York City now this this this this
fraud lawsuit I'll give you the
breakdown of my my prediction the first
thing the judge sarily rules that Trump
overvalued his properties it's clearly
not true because Mar Lago is not worth
$18 million it's crazy from the ocean to
the Lagoon Mar Maru Lago it's it's 17
half acres in an area where3 goes for
$10 million and they're saying 17 no
it's a lie but here's the game you
summarily decree Trump's properties are
worth less than he declared therefore he
committed fraud now the trial is did
Trump falsify records well if they've
already determined that his $500 million
property is only worth 50 million any
record he created asserting the value of
that property or a bank did they're
going to say it's falsified therefore
fraud they're going to rule that Trump
is found liable for fraud against the
state of New York they're then going to
say you now have to pay us $250 million
we'll start with that building on Fifth
Avenue that you claim was worth 500
million it's worth5 million you now owe
us $245 million what I think they're
going to do is by arguing his buildings
are worthless they can seize them in the
lawsuit while making him basically drain
the entirety of his net worth so uh the
reason I bring this up is you mentioned
the billionaires ruling the world
they're trying to make Trump a
billionaire anymore they destroy his
assets destroy uh the part of the uh
prosecution is not necessarily to put
him in jail though I do think they want
him there they want to drain his
resources time and energy so he can't
campaign that's what they did to Ralph
nater right they kept him so they kept
him off the bell and they kept him
spending money on lawyers and being in
court and so he couldn't really run for
president let me can I ask you about um
you probably know more about it than me
so this deal that they're they're trying
to prosecute him on now so he they said
he inflated the value of his building so
he could get a loan right so he got the
loan he's paid it back the people who
gave him the loan made money off that
loan there is no agreed party there's no
victim here am I right about this I
think I think what they're trying to do
is exploit the fact that the people in
New York struggle to own property and I
and I mean this I'm not trying to be
mean to the people of New York who can't
afford to buy but for those who've never
been through the process of buying
property it may sound like it makes
sense oh Trump claimed his building was
was worth more than it really was so the
banks would give him more money no no
when you try to buy property the bank
tells you to shove it we're going to
appraise the property and tell you if
you're and and see because we have we
have our own responsibilities to our our
bank members the idea that Donald Trump
went to the bank and said this uh $10
million property oh it's actually 100
million give me $100 million and they'd
be like sure thing buddy we we we'll
believe you and then we'll hold on to a
dead asset that's worthless no never
going to happen and on top of that the
judge ignored testimony from the lenders
who said not only are these properties
worth what they're worth but we made a
lot of money from it and we're happy
yeah and now you the funniest thing is
when the judge ruled Mar laga was only
worth $18 million I I just imagine what
it must be like being a real estate
agent in Palm Beach because now you've
got people coming up coming up to you
and being like n maro's worth 18 million
that means that that $30 million
property trying to sell is only worth
you know
$300,000 yeah right dude and have you
seen that J have you guys seen that
judge uh what was it Arthur and Goron he
first of all you want to I think Rob has
it the camera they're showing Trump and
you just see Trump just in Anger Furious
mode and then Jimmy the camera goes to
the judge he takes off his glasses and
he's like he's poed did you see that
video and then and then he's on another
longer video where they clip where he
says verba him me goes I know this is
going to be controversial because I know
I'm being recorded but he goes you know
there's a jury even though this isn't a
jury case this is who he is as a
character he goes listen if I'm in a
case and the jury doesn't agree with me
I could you know I can make my own
decision overrule them on my emotions
Rob can you show this clip is that cool
yeah go for yeah go listen to this guy
taped juries get it wrong a lot that's
my own opinion I do only civil
trials personal injury cases contract
disputes but I've had situations where
like Oh My My Heaven's
Sake how could they have thought that
the judge I have a um I have a tool that
I can deal with that it's called jury
notwithstanding the ver judgment
notwithstanding the verdict I can say
there is no possible way that a
reasonable jury would have reached that
conclusion like think about that's
that's the judge that's and then he's
not wrong though no he's not wrong at
all Jes can do this 100% but but I mean
like how is it fair if that's the judge
and then uh uh Leticia James the
Attorney General of New York she said in
an interview she was like I have no
personal Vendetta against Trump I never
campaigned against him and guess what
there's a there's a whole long footage
of her over and over and over
campaigning against him talking crap
about Trump in the streets so it's like
it's not fair by the way do you have the
clip do you have the clip for uh Hillary
Clinton what she said I'll read this to
you Hillary Clinton said back there
needs to be a formal deprogramming of
the Trump cult members Hillary Clinton
called for the formal d uh deprogramming
of the Donald Trump magga supporters
characterizing them as a part of a
called maybe they don't like migrants
maybe they don't like gay people or
black people or the women who got the
promotion at work they didn't Clinton
describes Trump as an authoritarian
populace who connects with a portion of
the prop base on an emotional
psychological level can you go and play
this clip wonderful clip by Hillary
partisans in both parties in the past uh
and we had very bitter battles over all
kinds of things gun control and climate
change and the economy and taxes but
there wasn't this little tale of
extremism waving you know wagging the
dog of the uh Republican party as it is
today and sadly so many of those
extremists those Mega extremists um take
their marching orders from Donald Trump
who has no credibility left by any
measure he's only in it for himself he's
now defending himself in civil actions
and criminal actions and when do they
break with him you know because at some
point know need to be formal
deprogramming of the cult members but
something need to happen here's a
question though here here's a question I
got for you so the only reason CNN would
put Hillary Clinton to give this Insight
is because they think Their audience
would react to it right you wouldn't
bring a guest and give him oh yeah and
then like the host is laughing as if
you're supportive what she is saying you
only bring it because you think
Democrats are still influenced by her
does she still have that kind of
influence over the Democratic voter I
think the Democratic party is a cult uh
you I call it blue andon and uh so that
that that's what that's exactly called
if you know about anything about Carl
Young that's classic projection right
there is what she's doing she's talking
about someone else being in a cult no
they're the ones who are actually
calling out the military-industrial
complex and right now people like Matt
gates are calling out the corruption in
Congress what she's talking about is
that they they all agree on corruption
we agreed on having the financial
services screw over uh people on their
credit cards she signed off to have 35%
interest rates she's the one who's the
enemy of the worker she the one there
were for every war possible she's the
one that keeps Health Care away from
people she the extremists are those
people and she again has to project that
onto other people uh and and then they
she's the one who invented Rush gate
right so Rush gate was 100% hoax that
was proven by Muller and then by the
Durham report it was all they're the
ones who financed Russian disinformation
which is what the steel dossier was
where did Christoper steel get that
information he got it from his contexts
inside the Kremlin they put it in the
steel report that's 100% right Russian
disinformation nobody talks about it
they lied that they funded it for a
whole year they lied to the FBI they
never have to go to jail for it because
they're lying at the behest of the
establishment and they got to get rid of
Donald Trump because Donald Trump
wouldn't do the interventions they
wanted he ran on pulling us out of the
Middle East they can't have that he said
there was a deep State and he gave away
our foreign policy so that's what this
is all about they of course the
Republicans and the Democrats they agree
on all the important things to screw
over regular people and keep the
military-industrial complex going
because they work for their donors
that's another version of her deplorable
speech and how did that work for her
Donald Trump beat you an election after
you called half the country deplorables
and she's trying to do that again so I I
have a question for you guys uh we we
have Hillary Clinton here saying that
there needs to be deprogramming what
people are referring to as essentially
re-education the former president has
been indied I think he's facing 91
charges it's going to put him in jail
for hundreds of years if he's convicted
they're trying to seize his assets and
his property and destroy him Capital
police are setting up offices around the
country they've raided the homes of even
in inocent people on accident we are
seeing the FBI now label Trump's
followers as extremists to be targeted
and my question is when you see these
things happening plus the indictment of
lawyers for the former president the
sanctioning I don't know how many people
know this many of the the lawyers that
were hired by Donald Trump and his and
his admin and his uh his C Inner Circle
in 2020 to argue on his behalf over the
2020 election they've been sanctioned to
the tunes of hundreds of thousands of
dollars for simply providing a
constitutionally in my opinion required
legal service what comes next they're
gonna they're they're calling Trump
supporters Trump's followers terrorists
and extremists they're say she's going
on TV saying they must they're a cult
that must be reprogrammed they're
arresting lawyers Mike cernovich tweeted
recently Perhaps hyperbolically Perhaps
a little bit aggressive that in in the
coming year if Biden wins something the
effect of he will be framed by the
regime for a crime that they will use
just to justify killing him and then you
have of course Scott Adams several years
ago said it's very likely that the next
year you will be dead well we're all
still alive but some people didn't make
it crime is getting bad and so I'm
wondering if Scott Adams and Mike
cernovich are seeing something
legitimate maybe their statements are a
little aggressive but my view is uh uh
Hillary Clinton adding to the
conversation we need to re-educate these
people the FBI report I'm curious what
you guys think happens next considering
all
this well I I heard there's a split
inside the military uh in the CIA right
so there's
General Flynn and uh who uh they' again
they've tried to make him out to be a
criminal they framed him to get him uh
to go along so this is this is what
they're doing so I hope that there's a
big faction of the military or some big
faction of the CIA that doesn't want to
go along with what's happening i' I have
I've heard that I don't have any direct
information but I've heard people say
that that I trust but I don't know I
don't have any evidence of it wait wait
wait real quick like I everyone makes
the meme about me saying Sil War but I
had not heard about the military having
a potential split no I'm just saying
that they back Trump and they back they
see what they see what the game that is
being played hey this is exactly what
they said what TR made Trump a fascist
was that he criminalizes his political
opponents that's exactly what they're
doing of course just like Hillary
Clinton that's all the back just like
what they're saying is happening in
Ukraine the exact opposite is the true
whatever you're hearing on the corporate
news the exact opposite is the truth so
uh so I don't know the only so I hope
this is true what I'm hearing I hope the
reason why Trump is running is to try to
run against the CIA and this
military-industrial complex I hope
that's what's happening because that's
what we need to have happen and we live
in a Banana Republic right now they're
really doing it it does like I said it
doesn't matter if you're trump it
doesn't matter if you're Maga doesn't
matter if you're Ultra Lefty they are
also doing it to Black socialists
they're also doing it to stop cop City
they Barack Obama in 2011 signed the
ndaa section 1021 which got rid of
habius Corpus so so that means that they
can throw you in jail and they don't
have to charge you with the crime all
they have to do is say you're a
terrorist well if you go out and protest
they're going to say you're an economic
terrorist or if you protest in oil well
they're going to say you're an you're an
environmental terrorist so they all you
do is say you're a terrorist they throw
you in jail and that's that and look
what they're doing to juliaan Nissan
still right out in the open and so
that's the and that's why none of the
journalists ever tell the truth about
Ukraine that's why they never tell the
truth about what's going on because they
know what's going to happen to them if
they actually put a hurt on the
establishment which is why we have
horrible journalism In America which is
why shows like this are popular shows
like Tim and M Joe Rogan Rusty Rockets
that's why these show Tucker Carlson's
killing it why because and Tucker
Carlson got fired people do he get fired
for lying that's the they he got fired
because he started telling the truth
about foreign policy economic policy and
the uh big Pharma and as soon as he did
that he became person n grada and they
had to get rid of him he got fired for
telling the truth not for lying and
that's what happens and that's what they
did to Julia nange that's what they did
to Edward Snowden so they and that's why
they have such control on us on YouTube
and we have to answer to billionaires
because that's who runs everything and
we're living people think we live in a
democracy it's a joke that they think
we're living in a democracy we live in
an authoritarian Nightmare and now we're
in a surveillance state where they don't
and we're operating on a Liberty View
from around the 1100s you know the the
uh habus Corpus was in the Magna Carta
they got rid of that so now we're
operating on a Liberty View from around
the 1100s and people don't even realize
it or care because people are too busy
trying to make a living and while while
they instead of them helping those
people they're taking that money sending
it to the military-industrial complex
via Ukraine that's it's a crazy world
we're living in and I wonder when the
real revolution's going to start because
the truckers let the template for that
so what the truckers did was they shut
down capitalism and they put a herd on
them so they immediately call them white
supremacists Nazis as they're literally
funding Nazis themselves and they're are
in bed with with Nazis that's what so if
somebody in America comes up with a plan
on how to do that to and if it comes
like from a Christian Smalls who knows
how to bring left and right people
together and oppose the establishment
like he did on Staten Island with Amazon
so if the and the truckers get together
with a union leader like that and they
can start making demands and and hook up
with like a Matt Gates inside of
Congress that's when a real Revolution
is happen that's the only thing that's
going to save this country at this point
and Tim can I you one question Tim off
the the FBI creating the mag extremist
category for Trump uh extremist what's
their criteria to find out and label you
and put you in that group like how what
how what's the FBI going to monitor like
if you have the flag on your truck are
they going to come after you because
Jimmy you nailed it on January 6 uh the
chief of capital police Steven son told
everybody they wouldn't let him testify
he was like I was begging for for help
they didn't give me [__] I wanted the
National Guard just like you said FBI
rups everybody getting getting they caus
all this thing and now they're warning
us I think cuz because they know
something is going to happen for this
election now they're going to go after
anybody that has any type of say but I
want to know what what do you think is
going to be their trigger to go after
you like what if you just say hey I like
Trump they're going to monitor your ass
sounds like it I I I refer to things
like this like I call it a Chinese
finger trap problem yeah in that uh The
Establishment is panicking over the
likes of Matt Gates anti-establishment
podcasters and individuals and so when
none of the propaganda is working
anymore none of the media narrative is
working they go for the brute force
method but guess what the harder you
pull with in a Chinese finger trap the
tighter it becomes so when they make
moves like this I have to wonder I'm
like are they that stupid because if you
got a bunch of people who are concerned
the government spying on them and
persecuting them and then you publicly
announce like actually we're totally
doing that the only thing it results in
is more
destabilization I'm not you know looking
at what comes next I don't think uh uh
people often look to uh tropes in
history TVs and movies and that's wrong
they make assumptions you know we hear
you know Alex Jones yell 1776 will
happen again and I'm like that that
wasn't the start of the American
Revolution the American Revolution
revolutionary period started in 1764 it
was 11 years before the first shot was
fired 11 years and you know what the
founding fathers were doing for those 11
years they were pampling they were going
around and they're kind of doing what
we're doing they're saying freedom
Liberty the oppression is wrong the
founding fathers did not want to go to
war they kept writing strongly worded
letters to the crown being like we
deserve representation and then what
happened was I'll give you a super
simplified version of it the the it was
the the te act I'm probably getting the
name wrong they uh the crown was trying
to subsidize the East India Trading
Company which was on was facing dir
Straits so they said we're going to make
it easier for them to sell tea in the
colonies and around the world which
directly competes with the tea from the
colonists which is going to hurt their
ability to make money so colonists got
mad they throw the tea in the in the in
the bay and they're like screw your tea
you can't do this the crown then says
you got to pay back all the money for
that damag tea Massachusetts then says
screw you the crown then says we're
sending in regulars to maintain order in
the Massachusetts colony because y'all
are acting a fool a bunch of farmers
outside of the city proper in the more
rural area said you have no authority
over us the regulars were then
instructed to go take the guns away from
these men and I think it was only a
small group of individuals at Lexington
and Concord when the regulars came and
said you're going to give us all of your
guns they said no we're not no one knows
exactly who shot first I think based on
what I read it was probably an American
colonist to open fire shooting a regular
and that was the shot heard around the
world not literally but that's the
moment they call it the shot around the
world which started the American
Revolution one year before the
Declaration of Independence what I see
happening now in Philadelphia in
California absolute destabilization when
you got a 100 people running through the
streets smashing Windows stealing
products and looting for no reason just
because these flash mobs keep happening
what's starting to happen is that these
individuals view the state and law
enforcement as a joke the way I explain
it to people imagine if a bunch of
clowns literal clowns with big poofy red
hair clown noses walked up to your door
banged and showed you a a clown portrait
and said this clown portrait gives us
the right to enter your property in
search everything you'd laugh right
you'd say what is this a clown now when
we see law enforcement the warrant we
are socialized to be like this is the
norm and these are the rules and we have
to we have to obey them but when you see
people ransacking businesses it's
because in their mind when they see a
cop they see a clown they do not see
that person as someone with authority
over them at all when this
destabilization starts happening it'll
happen and it's happening all over the
place with with with riding what you're
seeing is that kids growing up today
these younger kids are teenagers they're
young adults do not view the United
States government in any capacity as
having authority over their lives what
happens then in New York when the riots
got crazy what did the city government
do they do what governments always do
they circle the wagons around themselves
and they leave you high and dry yep when
these things start happening you get men
and militias forming which is what you
see in the likes of lexingon and
conquered what I see happening next is a
potentiality I don't know for sure if if
you look at what happened with the Bundy
Ranch incident now almost 10 years ago
when the federal government starts
circling the wagons around itself over
the conflict and the crisis determining
that Trump's voters are all are all
extremists and terrorists eventually law
enforcement shows up to a small town for
some reason or another and some local
guys who are in their 30s with body
armor and gun say we don't recognize
your Authority we don't care for your
Authority you don't protect us we don't
pay you you have no Authority here in
fact what ends up starts happening is a
local person will declare themselves a
sheriff they'll vote on it and then
they'll say we're the authority here not
you now you have governments at odds
with each other civil war is not people
make this mistake they think it's that
there's going to be a big faction of
States they stamp a paper and say we
hereby declare Civil War and that's not
what's going to happen what's going to
happen is that as the government loses
control because people no longer view
them as the Monopoly on violence
factions start popping up then the
government circles the wagons around
themselves and then you have multi
factions multiple factions in various
parts of the country we've already seen
this start with things like Chaz chop or
otherwise
ofs by call supporters terrorists they
are outright telling you you are not
protected by us you are not a part of us
but we will take your money and use it
against you this kind of [__] freaks me
out so that that and my theory is that
they this whole thing game by The
Establishment the oligarchy through
their corporate media is to keep us
distracted and hating our neighbor and
blaming our neighbor and being afraid we
got to be afraid of white supremacy we
got to get after we elected a black
American uh president twice in a row all
of a sudden racism is going crazy we got
to worry about white supremacy all of a
sudden and so and your neighbor's a
white supremist and your neighbors a
qinon and your neighbors this and your
NE and they want us to be hating each
other and fear each other because if we
don't we'll join together and we'll see
the game that's actually being played on
us and that will happen what he just
described a lot sooner when we don't see
the legitimacy of the government
governing us because they're governing
for the donor class and not for us and
so that's why they got to keep us
distracted hating that's why they got
have Hillary Clinton on CNN saying we
got to deprogram Maga they're the real
threat the real threat as we all know is
the government and Corporate America
that's the real threat and and you know
what I think I see happening is when you
get uh we've already seen videos since
the 2020 riots where there there's one
video where a car is driving by and you
see like three guys with AR-15s and body
armor at the end of their block and
these are probably just local dudes who
knew each other who said Guys these
rides are bad let's go stand watch and
make sure nobody comes onto our street
and screws with our friends and family
that's how it begins eventually they're
a neighborhood watch or they have a name
they need a way to recognize each other
now there's too many members and like
well let's give ourselves you know like
a code so that we know who's who's who's
helping protect the neighborhood they're
going to have other neighbors The Divide
you're talking about Jimmy where you
might have like some guys who are uh
black lives matter activists but then
what's going to happen is the BLM guys
in their neighbor be like look all we
want to do is make sure our kids are
okay and nobody's coming and screwing
with us and we don't trust police and
then these other guys are going to be
like yeah they called us terrorists we
don't like them either yeah and that's
when you get multiple factions and
they're all pointing at the government
let me put it this way if BLM is saying
police are bad abolish the police they
oppress us and now the feds are going
after Trump supporters as terrorists
you're very very close to BLM and Trump
supporters being like I'll do me you do
you let's not fight each other but those
people hate us yeah and how do you
deprogram these people cuz you you you
said a unique word over there you said
this is also called re-education I hate
to break it to you Hillary Clinton
you're not going to convince these guys
to vote for you I don't know what
reprogramming or deprogramming even
looks like for something like that but
these are some of the same people that
would have voted gladly for Bernie
Sanders in 2016 he do not want the
establishment the status quo the
business as usual typical talking head
politician in there so how do they
deprogram these people it's never going
to happen I think the opposite is
happening I think uh in in 2020 before
20 2019 it's a 2020 cycle a lot of the
people that I talk to when you quote
unquote touch grass you go out to the
real world right you get off the
internet they were saying things like
I'm in an Uber and the guy's just like
I'm sick of trump I'm sick of the
division if we just if we vote for Biden
it goes away and I'm I'm telling him I'm
like you know Trump's not the cause of
this he's a symptom of it and so what
I'm seeing now and uh it's a story that
I've been telling I I was hanging out at
the poker tables in uh Charlestown West
Virginia and you get you get some people
it's it's a mixed area actually in the
Eastern Panhandle so I get one guy
recognizes me and says you think Trump's
going to win blah blah blah and I said
they might take his name off the ballot
in one state and then who knows what
happens one guy chimes in and goes I
hate Trump but man this stuff's freaking
me out they shouldn't be doing this and
so what I'm what I'm hearing now and
I've heard this a couple times so it's
very anecdotal is that typically the
people who would say Trump's the cause
of the problem are now realizing Trump's
not the president anymore and they're
not stopping and the the persecution the
political persecution and the
weaponization of government is starting
to terrify the people who are begging to
be left alone the people who are begging
to be left alone I don't think will'll
ever take a barms and go fight or
whatever but they'll vote and they won't
vote for Democrats I'm not saying
they'll vote for Trump either but now I
think they're scared and they're
starting to realize that vote for Biden
didn't end the culture War it made it
worse yeah and and then so I want to ask
both you guys a question Jimmy and Tim
so you know a lot of people myself
included 2020 wasn't a free and fair
election with federal agencies involved
FBI Twitter all that stuff are you guys
concerned because think about it Trump
all these what 91 uh charges all this
stuff he's still beating Biden they know
it they're not stupid do you guys think
Jimmy something's I mean we talked about
in The Green Room something's coming do
you feel like something manufactur it's
coming they've been warning us about a
bunch of different stuff from pandemic 2
and all this stuff they're not winning
like is something going to happen that
you guys think it's going to to where
they can come in and and put all these
FBI people and everybody Yes Man they've
manufactured so I think I'm under the
belief that most of those black Liv
matter protests were half manufactured
by the FBI in the Deep state to create a
a sensation of chaos to make people
afraid of a Civil War coming they don't
care they a civil war is helpful to The
Establishment because then we're all
distracted and they get to keep doing
everything they want to do so yeah I I'd
be afraid the the infiltrators are the
FBI the CIA the Deep state they're the
ones who are going to probably do
something you're right and they'll going
to do it then oh now we have to give
martial law now we have to crack down
now we have to do just like they did
with lockdowns and and we already live
in a surveillance State and half the
country more of it's for censorship
which is you know that's that old saying
that the price of Liberty is eternal
vigilance and so people aren't being
vigilant now and we're giving away our
Free Speech we're letting journalists
that are are being prosecuted right out
in the open like Julian Assan and so yes
they will do whatever it is and if it if
they need to create a c a quasi Civil
War or a chaos they're going to do it
they've already been doing it and you're
exactly right I think people are
starting to wake up just like stop cop
City they use the same Rico statutes the
same Rico uh grand jury that prosecuted
Trump they did it to stop cop City and
so people I think are way like wait the
enemy of my enemy is my friend right so
we all have the same enemy it's the
government they're using the same thing
just like you described that's a perfect
way to put it and I hope people are
waking up to that now uh I hope it
doesn't come to Violent the Civil War
before people realize the game that's
happening but I really do hope people
like black lives matter and the people
that you described are going to come
together and realize hey uh it's the
illegitimate government and we need to
come together I really hope that happens
the first thing I want to say is a civil
war is an excellent opportunity for the
establishment because they could destroy
the Constitution if fighting happens it
gives them an excuse but the other thing
I want to say is you look at what
happened in New York with that guy who
got murdered that Ryan Carson the
attitude from the right is I don't what
was that story so uh uh Ryan Carson and
his girlfriend Claudia I think her name
is Claudia Morales they're sitting on a
on a bus bench now the media's reported
they're waiting for a bus but I don't
believe that makes sense a man an
18-year-old uh young black man walks
past them almost immediately after we
have the video they get up and follow
him the dude then scream starts attack
he's pushing a scooter I don't know what
Carson says to him or or or but for
whatever happens next uh Brian dling the
man in the sweater allegedly says who
what what the what the fer are you
looking at I'll kill you right now
mother
effer comes at him Carson pushes him
stands his ground pushes him again dling
slaps him Carson pushes him tries to run
trips falls dling stabs him three times
with a with I believe like a 6-in blade
piercing his heart and killing him now
the thing about the story is look this
stuff happens right the this guy was a
leftwing activist who worked for leftist
nonprofits and uh that that's that's him
dying right now and uh uh the response
from the right is you reap what you sow
sure when I looked at stuff like sop cop
City we've had our complaints about what
we're seeing across this country with
destabilization and law enforcement
targeting J Sixers while the Chaz chop
was and and and the the George Floyd
autonomous Zone the Atlanta autonomous
Zone were largely ignored now we're
seeing stop cop City actually they're
like you mentioned they're getting the
RICO charges they're bringing them in
when I was saying it's going to come to
the point where Maga and BLM are just
like yeah okay we you do you we do us
but those people hate us we're at the
point now where people are looking at
these cities and being like well you
voted for it it's all you I think we to
the point where yo stop cop city is not
going to appear on the radar of most
Trump supporters they give a sh [__]
about what's going on in in an urban
center that the left has taken has has
has run the way they want to run so
you're going to get Trump supporters
focused on their areas where they want
to protect their families if it comes to
the point you know right now a lot of
people's concerns with things like stop
cop City and these autonomous zones is
that it's destabilizing it's not good
but if we come to the point where
they're calling Trump supporters
extremists and then Trump supporters
circle the wagons around their areas and
then the left circles their wagons
around their areas you've got three
factions you've got the establishment
the government and then you've got the
left and the right I don't see the left
and the right fighting each other over
cities Republicans are leaving cities
they don't want to be there more more
conservative leaning people are moving
out of these cities Miami dat I think is
one of the exceptions that went red but
then you're going to it's like hey
that's your place I don't I don't care
the question is going to be whether or
not people are dissociating themselves
from the federal government you know how
local it becomes if it does break out
how long how long can one be manipulated
how long does it take until somebody you
said a you said a quote uh Tubman before
we got started we were not live if you
want to repeat the quote which one the
quote about the fact that I would have
freed more slaves Harriet Tubman yeah
Harriet Tubman said I freed many slaves
I would have freed many more If Only
They knew they were slaves If Only They
knew they were slaves okay so let's
let's some people you can't do anything
for some people can manipulate forever
right but you can't manipulate everybody
for a long time when parents get a
divorce typically one of the parents can
manipulate the kids to believe the other
parent was the bad parent and they'll
get away with it for a year 3 years 5
years 10 years but but you can't do it
permanently eventually a kid's going to
grow up and say listen I understand what
you're saying I don't fully buy into it
now I think you were wrong Dad I think
you were wrong Mom on what you did XYZ
right and the question then becomes how
many people are right now sitting there
saying dude I think these guys are
pinning us against each other well let
me let me let me point something I got
this very delicious uh Vault phenomenal
drink how's your brain feel that feels
great and people can probably tell I'm
like talking a million miles an hour
this black cherry delicious energy drink
that you guys made has no sugar in it
yes so what happened to 100 Years of
advertising from Coca-Cola where finally
we broke out and said we don't want that
high fru toast sugar garbage in our
drinks we want something that's
healthier that's got you know natural
sweeteners and so you look at propaganda
and manipulation let's go back to
marketing and advertising Coca-Cola ads
across the board in every country a
dollar for a Coke we make it affordable
for everybody and we have a whole
generation that don't doesn't want to
drink soda somehow we broke that
multi-billion dollar a year machine to
prop propagandize us into drinking
garbage and they roll out in the 80s
these artificial sweeteners and we all
buy into it but now all of a sudden
you've got a generation of people and
more being like we don't want aspartame
we don't want Splenda we don't want high
fructose corn syrup right Stevia is a
leaf extract or monk fruit and now you
know what's really funny is I'm seeing
everybody drink these spin drifts have
you seen them it's it's it's club soda
and lemon juice it's like sugar-free
lemonade we broke the manipulation we
broke that propaganda right so it's
possible and maybe maybe it's years I
don't know but the most powerful
propaganda machine outside of the US
government I think is these these
massive uh uh dopamine stimulating foods
and stuff that they want people guzzling
and drinking and if we can stop drinking
Coca-Cola and I think especially now
with conversations like this we're not
drinking the the the garbage of the
government then I think the manipulation
breaks at some point you know you know
where I'm going with this I'm sorry go
ahead Jimmy no I just wanted to say that
we eat so much crap in this country like
I was just in Italy and you know they
don't spray their their wheat with the
isop fate right like we do so if you eat
pasta here or what and or everything's
got that so corn the way they make corn
in America right so Bobby Kennedy
explained it to me on the show is that
they put this glyat they figured out if
they genetically modified corn you can
put
glysophates this corn so now that's what
and then Corn's in everything they put
that high fructose corn St even in bread
you can't get so that's in everything
it's in all your wheed it's in all your
bread and so that's why we're so sick as
a goddamn country we're getting sicker
and sicker and sicker we're not getting
healthier and healthier it's because all
the goddamn poisons we're eating in our
food when I worked for American Eagle
Airlines we would do deicing in the
winter I'm at Chicago O'Hare Airport and
I'm up in this big cherry picker on top
of a truck with this big hose over my
shoulder and a lever I would pull and
blast something called propylene glycol
onto these planes propylene glycol is
used as an antifreeze it has two two
formulations one was a 50-50 water uh
water mix which was hot and it was hot
propylene glycol to blast the ice off
then we would use a 100% pure propoline
glycol to then keep the ice from forming
the ice are on the planes right they put
this in muffins at gas stations oh what
they say it's fine for you to eat don't
worry and apparently what it does is
it's this gel when you add it to muffins
and food it makes it seem oily because I
love that part of it damn it when you
make a cake you put oil in it and that's
what makes it gooey and delicious and
look it say it's recognized it's by safe
by the F uh da are you kidding me how
does that
now hold on you it may be the case that
like just because I use it as antifreeze
on an airplane doesn't mean it's literal
ethylene I think it's ethylene glycol
which is you do not drink that goes in
your engine but when I worked for
American Eagle they said keep it off
your skin avoid contact cover your mouth
and avoid getting large quantities on
you the FDA says it's safe but we're
advising you not to get it on you and
there was even a story one guy said that
his buddy walked out of the break room
and he pointed at him and just blasted
him with it cuz they thought it was safe
and I'm like bro they thought his
bestest was safe okay how many they
thought cigarettes were safe agent
orange so but look you know where I'm
going with this though this this this
the part about manipulation that I'm
talking about I think all of us have
been manipulated before you have I have
got the V yeah well there you go highest
level of manipulation right but we've
all been manipulated before nobody is uh
free from that okay we've been ripped
off before we've been
manipulated yesterday I'm talking to a
Prager us CEO Marissa straight she's
here she's doing a show with me you know
she's interviewing for the show and
she's talking hey what do you think
about what's going on in America and all
this stuff I said what is the business
model of a divorce attorney think about
a business model of a divorce attorney
think about a business model of a
nuptial agreement attorney what do they
do this is how typically starts you'll
say hey babe you know let's just get all
this stuff on paper because I love you
you love me let's get on paper in case
who knows what's going to happen 5 10 15
20 years from now I just want to make
sure we're both protected okay I'm game
why don't we come up with the term terms
and then we go to the lawyers and then
we say this is what we agreed on so you
guys agree what if this happens what if
that happens what if this happens what
if that happened you do hours of the
conversation then you hire a lawyer you
have to have your own lawyer she has to
have her own lawyer okay you call the
lawyer and say how much does it cost to
put a ntial g my husband and I have
already agreed on all the terms the
lawyer says oh no more than $3 to $5,000
oh fantastic let's do it then comes the
first meeting okay hey here's what we
agreed on she gives it to her lawyer he
gives it to his lawyer her lawyer says
um Mary you know I don't mean to intrude
I know you guys have agreed on this but
this is the lowest I've seen a wife get
out of all the wives I have been doing
upal agreements for I I'm not I don't
want to create cause anything but I I I
don't know I think you should you know
maybe increases would you like me to
bring it up to the attorney so then the
wife sits there and says what well yeah
okay sure so so then wife gives a lawyer
the permission lawyer calls his lawyer
the lawyer's like what are you talking
about they already agreed on this well
she wants more on this then his lawyer
calls who calls him oh God and he says
what did she say and then he calls who
the wife and he like what are you
talking about well babe she said no wife
da d d i like we agreed on this what are
you talking about fight breaks out right
what happens behind closed doors the
entire time you're thinking your lawyer
is on your side her lawyer is on her
side but the reality of it is the
lawyers are on each other's side W the
more conflict they create between the
husband and the five wife a month later
two months later the bill comes
$1,728 what's this I thought I said
three to five yeah but I didn't think
you were going to have all these other
changes you asked for I never asked for
the changes you caused it what's going
to cost 11,000 this what's the point I
think these divorce lawyer nuptial
agreement lawyers are actually the
establishment
this is the Perfect Analogy where
they're using the parties on different
sides who may different certain like
right now you said I disagree with Matt
Gates on this on this on this but I
agree with them
on so what's starting to take place is
on Democrats and Republicans are like
look dude if there's something we're
both on the same side with I'm
anti-establishment Muslims and
Christians dude I'm against what they're
doing with you know these kids lgbtq I'm
Pro family I'm GNA you cannot touch me
we're on the same page wait what
Christians and Muslims yeah BLM and this
me was dude I can't stand the fact but
we're on the same page with this
families I'm living in Chicago you know
you're coming to use my gym for migrants
what the hell are you talking about this
is my gym for my kids and Republicans in
Texas we got to protect the Border I'm a
republic you're but dude we're on the
same so what's happening all of this
manipulation people aren't starting to
realize we're on the same page when it
comes down to them forcing us what to do
I'm not for this anymore and then what
happens with the gallop holes it's it's
shown what it's shown what happens with
Ukraine well but the but the part that's
the hardest thing to do the hardest
thing to do is the lifespan of
manipulation it's the lifespan of
manipulation is it one day is it one
month is it one year is it 10 years is
it 50 years you joined a feminist
movement 50 years ago and you're 68
years old now guess what it's too late
cuz they got you for 50 freaking years
our job is to try to shorten the
lifespan of how long we're manipulated
the shorter we're manipulated the sooner
we can be like whoa whoa whoa I'm free I
see it I see what's going on but so the
goal is for us to kind of go and boom no
I get it I see what you guys are
doing I'm not with it that's the part
where I see hope in both Sid seeing that
the divorce attorneys are trying to
create a divorce in America to make more
money and fees on the back end I think
the American people are starting to
realize what's really going on but I I
think that's fair if you were to let
take a look at someone like me or
someone like Jimmy where Jimmy I think
you have more economically left views
than I would I'm more probably moderate
maybe I would say I I'm you know I
usually view myself economically a
little bit to the left but then there's
someone like luk rowski who's a friend
of mine who's very like anarco
capitalist free market yeah I agree with
you there and I think those realizations
have happened when when Jimmy's praising
Matt Gates because Matt Gates is
basically challenging The Establishment
that happened but i' see too many people
who have millions of followers and go on
social media and they make videos where
they're like we should be at war in
Ukraine and that is the establishment
yes so it's not just like yeah yeah but
they're part of the camp that's that's
still manipulated that's what I mean by
it because people fall in different
camps there's still part of the manipula
C for example you got a guy that didn't
get the vaccine did you get the vaccine
or you didn't did you okay so there's a
folks that didn't get the vaccine right
there's a folks that only got one shot I
know guys that only got one of the shots
of Johnson Johnson there's guys that got
two of the shots there's guys that got
the two shots in the first booster
there's guys that got the second booster
then stop the third booster then fourth
booster and then there's people that are
still taking all of it right like Kelsey
coming out saying hey get your two shots
after your dny Taylor Swift come and get
the fiser shot all I'm saying is some
people are continuously being
manipulated some people are dropping off
so I think what you're describing would
then be uh it's it's kind of a a a
Corruption of what Andrew breart had
said a long time ago but I imagine it
like we we have all jumped through the
wall of fire imagine there's a there's a
fire and there are a lot of people
you're describing that are still
manipulated and they're told if you go
through that fire you will burn it will
be it will be hell don't do it don't do
it and then some people finally break
jump through on the other side they're
on the beach there's a party happening
we're all here we all we disagree on a
lot of things we agree on a lot of
things we're Left Right Center you know
varying degrees of libertarian some
people even authoritarian but just don't
like the way it's being run now and
they're arguing with us because they
realize the machine's been lying I would
say that the manipulation right now is
those you can call it those in The
Matrix those outside of the Matrix there
are there are leftwing individuals who
are friends with right-wing individuals
and debating these ideas and they're all
called rightwing because they're outside
of that field of manipulation that
you're describing so I I I suppose we're
on the side where we're having the
debate and we don't know everything but
we're trying to figure it out many of
these people are Marching In lock step
with the official corporate you know
government narrative so when when the
manipulation on them breaks well we win
right yeah but but but you're thinking
we have to be at 100% to win we never
like that we have could be 30% it could
be 20% it could be 10% it's a lot
smaller like a a organization where $3
trillion was founded by two guys called
Apple Steph and Steve right it took two
guys to build a three trillion doll
organization with a vision they had and
then they recruit all the other people
and the company got bigger and bigger
and bigger but the reality of it is you
don't need as many True Believers as you
think you need Joe was one guy Joe Rogan
is one guy right what did he do with his
podcast he went from being a you know
Pro smoke weed legalized marijuana
documentaries okay then that happened
hey I'm Bernie Sanders this is what I'm
doing okay oh [__] Joe for Bernie and
it's like uh vote Republican wait what
how did you go through this Evolution
right and then Elon Musk is saying the
only way we can save it is vote
Republican it's kind of weird what's
going on but all I'm saying is I think
the I think every one of us whether it
comes down to financially our health you
know either we're too lazy to want to
learn for ourselves right like the other
day we're sitting here with Liz wheeler
and we're talking about whether LeBron
James's wife ordered steroids and ped
and is is she kind of using an a PD kind
of like pton Manning's wife had the same
thing and are they goingon to do what
they did to Lance Armstrong and then I
you know she's like well you know do
it's not fair that these guys are using
all this stuff I said listen everybody
in America knows how to get a sixpack
how come we don't have six-packs
everybody in America knows how to get a
sixpack to tell me one person that
doesn't know how to get a sixpack don't
eat sugar you know don't eat BS food
change your diet do five minutes of abs
every day within 12 months you're going
to have a six-pack if you do the thing
but how come so many so few people have
six-packs because it's hard to do so
either we're not willing to put the work
to get clarity for ourselves or we are
simply caught in the web of being
manipulated for too long and we're not
free yet you know you know something
amazing is uh Ian Crossland who's uh one
of coasts on IRL he he weighed 127
pounds 127 pounds and uh we were
shooting a music video and we were we
told him like part of it is we're going
to film it in three parts over six weeks
so we need you to work out he's kept
working out you know why it feels good
it feels so good so it's hard to start
super likable guy yeah
superable just one last thing too and
you know I think of this too Jimmy it's
like the American people are so
traumatized with all the stuff that
we've been talking about it's almost as
if they have like civilian Stockholm
syndrome that and you know what it is
it's where the the abused falls in love
with the abuser and it's like they're so
like attached and we you know this is my
we they can't get that that mindset
switched around I mean unlike us these
PE I I I think it's I I I have hope but
I think that they're too embeded and to
in love with the system do you want to
publicly announce that you're joining
the club of five people I'm joining the
you want to do that or no no I'm not
going to do it you're not going to do it
you're going to hang in there cuz we're
going to go for another hour just then I
have to then you go do your okay so let
me go to the next story all right next
story Jimmy so the santis okay the Sanz
Ronda Sanz we're talking about all this
stuff some Republicans are not Trump at
all we had an kther here lost her mind
on anything good to say about Trump and
she's Pro the santis that's who she
would like to see as a candidate by the
way so are a lot of other people that
are part of this they're not sitting
they cannot stand Trump and they can't
even stand thinking about the idea of
voting for Trump so Ronda santz Jabs
Trump says he would be a lame duck
president if elected this is a CNBC
story Florida Governor Ronda Sanz and a
CNBC interview criticized Trump
electability stating he would be a lame
duck on day one if he could even get
elected the santis express doubts that
Trump's ability to address key issues
saying I think he'd have major problems
with personnel and a point and pointed
out that Trump failed to drain the swamp
and uh make Mexico pay for the border
wall the santis highlighted that Trump's
record emphasizing that Trump increased
the national debt by $7.8
trillion during his presidency and he
said and of course he didn't deliver on
his core promises the stist discuss his
strategy noting he would emulate
President Biden's approach by using the
budget reconciliation process to pass
his agenda when you hear these stories
of Dan santis going after Trump what do
you think about this is going to hurt
DeSantis in the polls why is that
DeSantis is playing a PO political game
during a culture war and so you look at
Ukraine and you look at a lot of these
issues uh Michael Moore put it best when
he said that uh Donald Trump was the was
a the biggest Collective Fu in history
that he would be a human Molotov
cocktail lobbed into the system now
that's a great speech he gave he then
goes on to say and they'll regret
they'll they'll like it for a month or a
minute and then they'll come to regret
it or whatever he said he was wrong
about that last part Ronda santz keeps
trying to play this policy game we love
the policy you know I was a big I I was
actually saying to sandis was the guy a
year and a half ago but what he doesn't
understand is the cultural issues and
what gets a president elected and it's
not this this is why I just I he's
dropped in the polls Nikki Haley is now
beating Ronda Sanders on predicted I
think his campaign has been too much has
been just too I want the right word is
stagi and uh uh it's it's it's not in
the the cultural Zeitgeist it is you
know he did a a bunch of things that
were really great in Florida he led the
country very well I think he's he did
fantastic job he's our best Governor I I
was saying for a while he was the best
politician in the country now I would
say it's Matt Gates but Ronda santis is
playing a game that no one else cares to
listen to at this point I think for the
most part it is sad it breaks my heart
to see all these really great policies
that he's talking about wanting to
implement but then his campaign has run
like a disaster disaster a complete
disaster and he doesn't have his finger
on the pulse of what's going on you know
what Andrew
what I mean he said what politics is
Downstream from culture Dan santis is a
policy wonk he probably is the best
policy guy on that stage but that's not
why Americans are voting right now there
nobody's like delving into Trump's
policy at all they're just going with
him because of his Persona they're
saying we have watched the capital
police expand Beyond DC into Florida
into California we there was a woman in
Alaska whose home was raid because she
looked like a woman who was in the
capital and so they said we're going to
break in her house you've got uh uh uh
en riario 22 years in prison despite not
even being there because he he posted a
message on parlor saying don't don't
eing leave or something like that Joe
bigs they said he get a terrorist he
gets a terrorist modification because he
knocked over he's accused of knocking
over a metal barricade and I'm like dude
look riding at the capital was bad the
dude should probably have time served
he's been locked up for two years over
this he walked around goofing and
laughing and and they gave him two
decades these are the things that are
freaking people out Ronda santis is
playing this game of well if you look at
our policies we've got to address these
issues meanwhile people are in solitary
confinement and we're going like we need
someone who's going to just scream at
these people and and I my thing about
Trump is I don't think he's going to be
the best president or the best guy for
the job I can appreciate no new Wars I
can appreciate his plans were withdrawal
I appreciate when he admitted American
foreign policy was hilarious and I think
he wants revenge and that Revenge means
he fires a lot of people who deserve to
be fired Ronda santis looks like he's
going to be a guy who's going to come in
and say well I'm going to try and get
done what I can get done to benefit this
country
but that means I got to play ball so I
don't get kicked out or attacked like
Trump does and that's the message of the
American political class for my entire
life of well if I push too hard they'll
OU me so at least I can get a little
change here what that basically means is
I'm going to swim with the current I'm
going to go with the flow with all the
school of fish and then maybe at some
point I might get lucky and add a grain
of sand to to to the Heap of change now
I'm not interested I want a human
Molotov cocktail I want Donald Trump to
go in and just be like I'm firing
everybody because I want revenge
whatever it is whatever it is not bad
I don't think Ronda santis is a Revenge
guy I think he's a policy guy and I
think he's going to play ball and he's
going to negotiate that's not good for
us Pat what are the chances that an cter
who was just here three days ago for is
actually advising DeSantis now because
if you look at what he's basically Des
santis is on the offensive now the
gloves are off he's basically calling
out Trump he wasn't doing that a month
ago he's saying he didn't dram the S
didn't build a wall you know promises
made promises unkempt that she must have
said wall how many times 65 times okay
so what are the chances that she's
advising Trump uh DeSantis at this point
I I don't I don't know I mean DeSantis
hired the worst possible campaign staff
in in the history of a president pres
it's probably not fair but in my
lifetime I can't believe the people he
hired his his his PR department
effectively started attacking everyone
in the most annoying and and Nails on a
chalkboard way and this caused them to
lose a bunch of their support the
desandis campaign actually has a an
internal medic that their people cannot
appear on my show because we criticized
Ronda santis not not a joke absolutely
serious people who are friends of ours
who have been on timcast irel before are
not allowed to come on the show we've
reached out to them saying hey look you
know we've had criticisms but we we like
him as a policy Guy come on nope won't
do it and I'm just like then then you
guys deserve to lose well we have this
is a this is the fourth time we're
trying that we got a I think third this
could be the third I could be wrong on
third or fourth time that we're getting
a dat on the calendar we're going to see
if this one's actually going to happen
or not it's in two or 3 weeks wait wait
so they keep canceling on you the the
weather was one issue and a couple other
things but this next one that we're
going to have is in two or three weeks
he's going to be here we'll see
obviously whether that'll happen or not
look but his his Guy Brian has reached
out multiple times saying we're going to
do this and we're looking forward to
having a conversation with them well
good good luck to you you know for us uh
when Ronda santis announced his campaign
on Twitter on X and it crashed and his
rousing speech was we we're leading the
Great American comeback I said that is
the the like least charismatic
announcement I've heard Barack Obama
stands in front of 10,000 people in
Chicago and he says and that is why I am
running for president they go they go
nuts Trump has the elevator moment these
Grand moments and Ron missed it you say
that one time and then all of a sudden
all of the people that support Ronda
santis will just level every possible
insult we had I had a debate between
Laura lomer and Bill Mitchell on the
culture War podcast my Friday morning
show and I asked Bill Mitchell why it
was that I keep trying to defend to S on
on policy and criticize him where I
think he deserves it but I think I'm
being reasonable why am I being called
an effing [__] piece of trash why are
people like just inundating me with
these nasty messages look I'm a man I
don't care you're saying it I'm telling
you it's hurting your campaign and his
immediate response was well L Laura
lomer posted a picture I said stop I
don't care about Laura lomer I'm I'm
this middle of the road guy who liked
the santis I am saying I I have some
legitimate critic ISM of him right here
here's why I like him why are you
insulting me and he goes well Alex Bruce
Switz I'm like there it is you lost you
lost Alex Bruce witz and Laura lomer
Master trolls they are huge Trump fans
they Laura LOM no one supports Trump
more than Laura lomer and they figured
it out they they insulted the disantis
campaign and the disantis campaign took
the bait and went nuts and started
attacking everyone in response I've had
people from I don't want to drag anyone
else this high-profile conservatives who
have never said a bad word of Dan santis
come to me and they were like I'm
getting attacked by the dis santis
people for some reason I don't know
what's going on and I'm like oh yeah
it's cuz his campaign staff are just
blowing up his campaign they wanted to
lose when I have a guy with two million
followers who is a fan of DeSantis and
he said all all that all that he did was
he said he he thinks Trump's going to
win based on the polls and they just
went after him insulting in every mean
and nasty way all of his surrogates they
said you're an effing idiot just like
nasty stuff and I'm like yeah I think
they want him to lose that's all I can
say it's it's it's the PO most poorly
run campaign I've ever seen you know can
I just change the subject a little bit
you're talking about when people start
to wake up and when do they stop being
manipulated when are people going to
realize so this I've had people say to
me about the Trump prosecutions and I
try to explain to them what this really
is is criminalizing the establishment's
enemies and they go but Jimmy Donald
Trump actually did break laws and I'm
like so you think we're supposed to
prosecute Donald Trump for whatever that
law is you think he broke when Dick
Cheney and George Bush walked Europe
they ordered a torture program and
Barack Obama was supposed to prosecute
those guys constitutionally required to
and he didn't and the reason why he did
well the public reason why is he said
that all those to torture crimes
happened in the past and Barack Obama's
looking towards the future which uh you
know all the crimes I've committed are
in the past too so I'm glad I'm glad
we're not Prosecuting those but uh the
reason why he didn't for real is because
he works for the same people and Barack
Obama was not a departure from George W
bush Barack Obama took us from two Wars
to seven Barack Obama kicked 5.1 million
families out of their houses while he
made sure that the bankers got their
bonuses Barack Obama deported twice as
many Hispanics as Donald Trump he built
those cages they put those people in he
dropped more bombs than George W bush
and so they'll and now they remember
they used to say they hated Ralph nater
because they he gave us George Bush well
now they all love George Bush because
George Bush called the people on January
6 terrorists so now the establishment
loves him again but they still hate
Ralph nater isn't that amazing so that
that's the what I hope people wake up to
that fact that if you're going to
prosecute Donal Trump it can't be
because he's breaking laws because we
already have people who are war
criminals every president's a war
criminal in my lifetime and not only
that they ordered a torture program and
Barack Obama said yep we tortured some
folks and then he didn't prosecute
anybody for it in fact they put one some
that uh thee of the CIA uh I forget her
name hasel and uh they put Gina hasel
right and they said oh she broke the
glass ceiling cuz she's the head of the
CIA yeah she broke the glass ceiling and
then she picked up one of those shards
of glass and started torturing people
with it Barack Obama killed a
16-year-old American citizen in Cold
Blood ordering a drone strike which
killed Abdul Raman alaki at a civilian
restaurant in Yemen a country we are not
at war with and when confronted luk
rowski if we are changed confronting
Obama's team at uh I believe it was like
a DNC debate in 2012 I think it was and
the response was he should have had a
better father uhhuh Barack Obama's the
official administrative response was
Oopsy Daisy oopsy oopsy daisy you
ordered a drone strike on a nation we
are not at war with a civili restaurant
with tons of collateral damage and
casualties killing a 16-year-old
American and and and do we get a
prosecution of of Barack Obama no no no
the reason he's not going to go after
bush is because he's playing the game
with them they work for like you said
work for the same company right now that
that article you pulled up from the
interet I want to bring that you can
pull that one back up Donald Trump
ordered a Commando raid in Yemen one of
the first acts which reportedly resulted
in the death of an 8-year-old American
Girl and I'll say this too there should
be an investigation into what happened
and how this girl died and if Donald
Trump is responsible for the death of an
8-year-old American Girl I want military
tribunals I don't care I want
investigation I want prosecution that
being said the Obama Administration
definitively we know for a fact it's
been reported far and wide and they've
admitted it ordered a drone strike that
killed these people the Trump
Administration ordered a Commando raid
however the current understanding we
have is that people have asserted the
Commando raid resulted in the death of
this girl it's not as clear I don't care
there should be an investigation of both
and if Trump is is cleared of wrongdoing
so be it if not lock them all up well
isn't that interesting that they're not
Prosecuting Donald Trump for that
exactly ex it just goes just because
they've all committed those crimes so
that's why it took them so long to
impeach Donald Trump they had to find a
crime that he committed that they also
didn't commit and are complicit in and
that's what so that's this is just a big
game it's obvious so I think people are
waking up to this is a political
prosecution of Donald Trump and that's
why every time he gets indicted his
numbers go up I'll I'll play this game
when when when some left or democrat or
whoever liberal neol says shouldn't we
hold people accountable for their crimes
I'll be like I'll make a deal with you
did you hear about how Trump killed that
8-year-old American Girl in Yemen
they'll like no like yeah look it up
look it up let's let's do this how about
we prosecute him for that yeah and then
when they say sure but great Obama's
next they'll go wait wait wait wait wait
wait no no no no I don't want to do that
right Tim what's the precedent for this
because you know Jimmy sort of alluded
to this that during his lifetime no
president has ever not killed random
civilians you know American citizens who
are constitutionally protected and Obama
killed anir alaki Abdul raman's dead so
the working theory is that Barack Obama
kills anir alaki admittedly saying well
he was a Jihadi I don't care there are a
lot of Americans in this country with
bad opinions you don't blow them up but
well you know Obama said he could do it
why then did his 16-year-old son die you
expect me to believe that it was an
accident you blew up a civilian
restaurant with this gu kidding it I
think Barack Obama was like I'm going to
make sure all these people who challenge
us no we we [__] kill kill your kids
and that's what he did when he killed
Abdul ran alaki I don't I don't believe
the the the the narrative from The
Establishment we we made an accident
when it was just an accident when we
were trying to get somebody else whoopsy
Daisy we whoopsy Daisy we were targeting
a terror leader and it just so happened
it was the 16-year-old son of the guy we
just killed so I think this is abject
Evil killing some dude's kid the kid
grew up in Colorado he lived in San
Diego he was born in Colorado he lived
in San Diego and he was killed by Obama
administration drone strike if you
accidentally kill an American citizen
guess what we lock you up MH now if you
want to make the argument that
collateral damage happens in war and we
give presidents a wide mandate on
recognizing that sometimes civilians die
in these conflicts and it sucks fine I
think it's [__] when we have the
video released by Julian nange
collateral murder where Reuters
journalists are are shot down by naache
and killed that the argument they give
us is like it was an accident we thought
they were armed and terrorists and the
American people typically buy this for
whatever reason I don't but when they
kill American citizens without charge or
trial I kind of think like hey you know
we've got evil people running our
country and they should be prosecuted
instead they go after Trump on BS about
his lawyers argued he won an election
and they filed the paperwork and they
did the alternate elector slates which
had happened before in 1961 I'm supposed
to care about that I'm supposed to care
about that when Julian Assange has been
locked up for the past decade and
they've effectively executed him they've
done it a way where they can prevent him
from being a martyr but they've
destroyed his life because he exposed
their war crimes I'm not I'm just I'm I
stuff gets me so piss
me too I'm right there with you by the
way let's talk about RFK and side note
if the santz you want him on your
podcast did you want him to go to West
Virginia or would you go to Tallahassee
to have him on well I think initially we
we we offered uh to come to uh Florida
we we've said the same thing for the
Trump team as well cuz like come on like
we're not going to tell someone you have
to come here that makes no sense in fact
we've gone to Congress TW uh twice I
think twice uh and did our show from
congressional offices because we know
that these guys are in the middle of a
vote they can't come but they can run up
do the show so you would go to
Tallahasse to interview the absolutely
well then that if that's the case I
think he should do your show I think
it's a it's a absolute must to go on
your show especially with the audience
that you have uh I thought maybe you
wanted to come to West Virginia and the
beach in West Virginia is slightly
different than one in Florida maybe he
would have preferred you coming paa
season though I mean it's a good time to
come yeah pawpaw you ever have one
what's that uh pawpaw no what's that
Apple West it's a hillbilly banana it's
uh uh it's like the northernmost mango
family fruit and uh
it's it's like mango and banana combined
and there there's tens of thousands of
them right now just falling everywhere
they good are amazing oh great yeah
they're amazing and you make banana like
you can make pow POA bread and stuff
with them you don't typically find them
in stores because they don't last that
long well just so you know we were going
to announce right now that was a perfect
mix the newest flavor of all coming out
West Virginia Edition the temp with his
on it so po pow coming out here soon
let's talk about RFK RFK RFK so poll
comes out RFK Juniors and independent
run could pull more from Trump than
Biden so a recent Quin uh uh quak quak
University poll indicates that RFK Jr's
potential independent run for 2024
presidency could
disproportionately affect Republicans
rather than Democrats notably the poll
shows that Republicans have a notably
higher favorability rating for Kennedy
with 48% uh having a favorable view
compared to only 14% on a Democrat side
so who would he take votes away from if
he were to run as an independent well I
think definitely would be more votes
from Trump and that's why the Democrats
forced his hand into leaving the primary
they they completely were rigging it and
cheating it and they were going to start
making him pay for the primary if he
wanted to have one so he had no choice
but to run independent and the reason
why the Democrats wanted him to do that
they forced his hand is because they
think he's going to take more votes from
Trump and I think he will because a lot
of people who want to vote for d for uh
Bobby Kennedy their second choice would
be Trump that no nobody's going to vote
for Bobby Kennedy their second choice
would be Biden nobody so but I think
what Bobby Kennedy's actually going to
do is Big bring people who don't vote
which is the biggest voting block people
who don't normally vote they're going to
see a reason to vote again because the
guy's really anti-establishment and I
think that uh what all The Independents
also which is the second biggest voting
block are going to be drawn to him so I
think that he might take votes from
Trump but I think he's going to energize
people who don't normally vote to come
out and vote I I'm I'm a little split on
this one uh you know when the story came
out I actually said I I don't think
it'll be from Trump because uh you know
Phil leonty on the show said in the most
eloquent way that Trump's bottom is
solid he's not uh his his his voter base
at 44% they're never going anywhere no
matter what and the poll showing that
Republicans have a have a higher
favorability of RFK is true because he's
anti-establishment doesn't mean they're
going to vote for him however that being
said I hear from a lot of people that
they're very very pissed off that Donald
Trump Trum backed fouchy didn't fire him
and all the co stuff and if rfk's
principal position is the anti-id stuff
Trump's still coming out and saying you
know that he saved 100 million lives
he's told his liberal friend said this
and he he he likes what he did I'm like
you're you might actually end up seeing
people be like I'll vote for RFK Jr it's
hard to know for sure uh we talked with
Rich bars the people's pundit and I
think the general assessment was Trump
will suffer from this but RFK will
likely split more Democrats I think
that's they're looking at and so it may
end up with a a situation where you have
Biden slightly below Trump and Trump
winning a state like Maine with with a
with 43% or something doesn't just show
how far left the Democrats have gone
well you're talking about the nephew of
JFK the Democratic president greatest of
all time right the son of Bobby Kennedy
murdered right uh now 48% of Republicans
identify with him what's the number 14%
of Democrats
he's no longer even beloved that the
kennedies are no longer beloved in the
sacred Democratic party he's now on the
Republicans things this is crazy I was
going say because it's a cult because
the Democrat whatever their favorability
is is marching lockstep RFK Jr was was
like moderate he's on gun control issues
right he he he a lot of trump supporters
are coming on being like have you looked
at him he's a liberal I'm like well of
course he's a liberal but he's
anti-establishment so now you like him
that's what it it really is the
Democrats are a cult in my opinion
called on yeah you know they they say
this a big tent party it's a big tent
party yeah as long as you just kind of
get in line and this is why the
Republicans are so divisive so they say
is because people have different
opinions all right we're GNA argue Matt
Gates Eric McCarthy where is a
Democratic party all right Bernie
Elizabeth Warren all right everyone get
ear I'm behind Biden now and that's just
how it works there's this weird
phenomenon now that I've stayed true to
what I thought used to make me a liberal
and a lefty which was freedom of speech
my body my choice bodily autonomy
anti-authoritarianism an anti-war and
now all those things have been turned in
they call you a right- Winger for that
if you're anti-war you're a right-
Winger you're a Putin puppet you're it's
the crazi so it's there's been this
shift in the parties so now when you say
that the Democrats have gone farther
left I say they didn't they've gone
actually further authoritarian and
establishment and there's nothing left
or liberal about the Democratic party
anymore they're corporatists and they've
tricked people into thinking that you're
actually a liberal or a lefty if you
vote for those corporatists Jimmy would
you break that down the four things you
said that made you a classic liberal and
how counterintuitive it is today well it
you said my body my choice said freedom
of spe that's not classic liberalism
okay Jim's talking about Tri traditional
liberalism okay but yeah continue I I'll
I'll jump in after so yeah I just always
thought what made me a lefty was that I
was anti-war I was anti-authoritarianism
I was for freedom of speech absolute
across the board and bodily autonomy my
body my choice that's all out the window
uh the the the Democrats have all
flipped on all those things they're for
sensor ship they're super pro warar
they're against your body my your body
your own choice it's your body my choice
well especially on Co that's what I'm
talking about just that's the only thing
that they think it'll well I've talked
to people about the vaccine mandates and
I go what about my body my choice and
literally they will say well that only
goes for abortion it's like what they go
yeah cuz abortion isn't contagious yeah
but I think your stupidity
is because you know what is contagious
the co 19 virus you know what doesn't
stop it from being contagious That
vaccine want to mandate because you've
been propagandized to think so and but
people are that's another thing you know
you brought it up earlier I wanted to
piggyback on it is that at some point
people stop taking the boosters right so
at some point they stop listening to St
fouchi and CNN and MSNBC and fox and
they stopped listening to the garbage
from the FDA and the CDC so at some
point they realized hey I think they're
lying well people they don't tell you
that the two heads of the in the FDA the
head of the vaccine Department the two
heads that were there there for 30 years
quit over the booster so it wasn't okay
for them but if I say something I'm
called a Trumper a white Winger a white
supremacist if I go along with the same
people who had the vaccine department at
the FDA when they resigned so anyway
that that's a long answer to your
question but those are the things so now
everything's flipped and now the only
anti-war voices are coming from the
Republicans they're for freedom of
speech they're for B for uh bodily
autonomy it's the craziest thing I've
ever seen so yeah I I've stayed
consistent and because I've stayed
consistent and the Democrats have become
authoritarian Maniacs Pro censorship
proar then if I'm against that you're
now a right-winger it's it's nuts so the
so uh classical liberal typically refers
to the founding fathers it's a more
libertarian view it's considered to be
center right libertarianism and then
traditional liberal they're very very
very similar but that's considered the
center left liberal 20 years ago when
I'm growing up my family are all what
would be described as social or
traditional liberals meaning we were
upset about racism we were upset about
pre prejudice we were upset about these
social issues and we had a very liberal
perspective but social liberals which
are uh social and traditional Liberals
are Democrats 102 years ago believed we
can probably help solve some of these
problems if we address them properly but
now you end up with the culture War
today because what do we end up seeing
they're they're advocating for racial
segregation we're seeing these uh the
libraries in Seattle where it's like
it's like uh uh what is it p po Dei
meeting uh uh nonp meetings in Dearborn
Michigan they did these digital cafes
where there was one for white people one
not for white people and I'm like yeah
I'm sorry dude that's that I call that
reactionary right they they try to call
us reactionaries in rightwing
reactionaries a reference to those who
tried to maintain the status quo in the
French Revolution so if my family uh uh
literally my my my parents my mom grows
up before loving V Virginia when
interracial marriage was illegal and
before civil rights and they had to lie
about the relationship of my grandfather
and my grandmother because if people
found out it was actually a felony and
they the flee several States then the
Law changes loving V Virginia comes down
there's a ruling hey guess what you can
be of any race and Mar if you want it's
kind of crazy to think that was illegal
it's called misation and then what
happens you get someone like Derrick
Brown the critical race theorist who
argues that school segregation plus EV
Ferguson all this stuff he wants the
segregation he wanted it and that's the
modern cultural left so that is that's a
huge component for me I'm like I
actually thought it was a good thing
that for for for one of the first times
in the history of humanity we were like
it doesn't matter what you're races and
now they're trying to rewind that clock
it's interesting you're saying this and
Rob you pulled this up I want to read
this to you diversity numbers among
delegates trigger alarm at DNC meeting
this is a political story October 3rd
DNC officials expressed concern about
failing uh falling short of diversity
goals in big States like New York in
California with down in Brazil noting
whether it's African-American Community
black community the lgbtq community
Hispanic Community numbers continue to
decrease the DNC uses a complex formula
based on eligible voters from Seven
targeted groups to calculate diversity
goals in California the proposed number
of black delegates is 12% roughly double
the percentage of African Americans in
the
state and the DNC is still in the
process of approving delegate proposal
plans for all 50 states in the district
of Colombia how diverse the convention
delegation will be remains uncertain and
increase competition from Republican
party for Latino voters adds complexity
to the DNC efforts so this is diversity
of skin color this is not diversity of
thought and so they they want to have
all the black brown Hispanic and all the
different uh ethnicities and sexual
genders but they we all want you to
think exactly the same and that's what
the Democrats are actually bragging
about that we're all in lock stab so it
doesn't matter that they have diversity
uh in ethnicity or diversity in skin or
they all have they have uniformity in
thought and that's what's going on and
it is a blue and on cult and you and
you're not allowed to question at all or
you're immediately shunned and called a
right-wing which is what I've been
called since I debunked Russia gate I
was the first one to debunk it on the
left I had Bill Bon told me for a fact
there's no way Russia hacked into the
DNC server and I knew it was a hoax ever
since then and so and Seth rich now they
don't even want to let the Seth Rich the
FBI first they lied and said they didn't
have Seth Rich's computer then they said
we did but we can't access it then they
said of course we got it we accessed it
but we're not going to share it with you
for 65 years so I guess I forgot how I
got started on this but that's the end
of it by the way this is this is the
reason why Nome cannot be a candidate
for 2024 as much as the left is dying
for him to be it he cannot be because
the only way Nome could be a
presidential cand we we've talked about
him potentially being the most
formidable one for sure but the only
route he can have for 2024 is for Biden
to have health issues and then camalo to
step aside and it's going to be a white
man African amican woman and Republicans
will come and say the organization that
says you're so diverse look what's
happening with you well let let me tell
you about the diversity thing uh I I I I
grew up in a family where uh mix mixed
race family um a second generation so my
grandparents on my mom's side Korean
woman white dude illegal crime and I
grew up hearing these stories from my
mom about people would insult her and
call her names and spit on her and
things like that I was like wow that's
crazy and then I see all this wonderful
stuff from the Democrats about unity and
no more racism and I was like we really
did it guys I'm this little kid with
glistening eyes I'm like it's so cool
that I got a friend who's Filipino I got
a friend who's from Poland I got a
friend who's black I got a friend who's
Hispanic man we're like that McDonald's
commercial for kids where it's all these
different people and I thought that was
normal to me on the south side of
Chicago where everything was very
diverse and then when I go to Occupy
Wall Street Occupy Wall Street literally
created racial caucuses they voted on
how to to spend money based on your race
so they had the black caucus and the
Latino caucus and the Asian caucus and
then they had the working groups and if
you were working sanitation meaning you
would clean the place your vote could be
overridden by a group of people just
based on their race and then I said what
the I was like are you kidding me I was
like I went through Stories the horror
stories from my family about racial
segregation and now y'all are doing it
that freaked me out and this this starts
on the path where I'm at Occupy Wall
Street I'm I'm a I'm a I'm a relatively
Lefty guy I've been my whole life
listening to an anarchist punk rock
Lefty communist garbage and uh good
songs still by the way but some of their
messaging I wake up to when I'm getting
older and I'm watching these people
racially segregate now I can't speak for
every single person who who he was in
the black Community or the Latino
Community the Asian Community because
we're all different my my experience in
life I totally recognize those arguments
from the left about the the difference
experiences we all have you know a black
Trans woman is going to have a different
experience from me a mixed race Asian
guy grew up in the south of Chicago but
I'll tell you this when when I have
these people tell me outright I got a
guy come on my show smacks the
microphone a white man comes on my show
and tells me I don't actually understand
oppression cuz I look too white anyway
wow I don't care that he can say those
things to me about the racial issue I
care that he's a hypocrite and when I
say to him your logic dictates you
submit to my worldview because I'm the
mixed race person who's been oppressed
by you white man they can't handle it
they their their logic is simply white
people are the oppressors and we're the
majority so you do what we tell you to
do and I'm like I'm not interested in
that I'm I'm more interested in people
who are like the uh there's a Yale study
that came out several years ago that
showed that white liberals talk down to
Black people and white conservatives do
not and I'm like I think that
exemplifies this quite a great deal well
but let me ask you this so when you were
at Occupy Wall Street and you saw them
siloing off into their little ethnic
groups right to when I see that now I
see that as coming from infiltrators and
that's exactly how the establishment
wants them to organize because if they
organized Al together they would be
formidable and they could oppose the
establishment but if they Silo us off
into lgbtq and trans and then to Black
and Hispanic and Puerto Rican and
everything so then we don't come
together and we keep fighting and that's
that's that's all that Dei stuff it
comes from Black Rock it comes from the
top down it doesn't come from the bottom
up which is what I was trying to impress
upon to Cornell West when he was on my
show you're repeating the The
Establishment talking points when you
keep talking about white supremacy and
lgbtq and trans they want you to keep
talking about that they don't want you
to organize long class lines so don't
you think that's that's go ahead you're
right uh the first when when I the first
weekend I was I Occupy Wall Street there
was a 60-year-old couple with an
American flag behind them they they
consider themselves constitutionalists
they weren't leftists they weren't
Communists they weren't Dei none of that
they were Libertarians I met Lukowski if
we are changed he's a free market inarco
capitalist kind of guy he was down there
too because the message originally was
the corporations the big Banks and the
government teamed up and screwed the
American people over and then there's
that famous meme comic where you've got
a bunch of PE there there's this fancy
looking room a guy at his desk and
outside the window is a bunch of people
protesting and angry holding up signs
saying we are the 99% and the smug guy
at the desk says introduce identity
politics yeah wow yeah so and and I
actually experienced the manipulation uh
I don't know how you find this one you
got to find like the comic of the of the
guy at his desk introduced identity
politics but there was a Civil War at
Occupy Wall Street the East and West
factions of there was the General Union
and the general assembly when everyone
talks about occupy they only ever tell
you about the general assembly there it
is on the left the general assembly was
the official narrative the media
supported and got behind and on the uh
other side of the park which would have
been I believe the west side of the park
was zoom in a little bit it was the
General Union these were actual
activists people who are typically
leftists who are trying to find a way to
organize and here's the funny thing
their organizing structure was based on
the family and these hippie Lefty guys
sleeping in a park told me the family is
the most important political unit which
is really funny because you hear this
from Trump supporters and this is like a
this is a leftist guy in all black punk
rock and he said here's how we want to
organize we all have 10 tents each tent
is a family our representative of our
family will come and speak to the
general Union about how we distribute
Goods when they tried holding a meeting
and raise raising funds facilitators
they called themselves showed up and
took their meeting over in the most
cultish and psychotic way anytime one of
these activists would try and make a
statement the facilitators would go mike
check mike check mik check and the whole
crowd would start chanting mic check and
just stop talking go to these activists
I'm in San Bernardino
Trump supporters and you know quotequote
leftists and I walk up with my camera
and I was like hey you guys are
protesting would anyone mind answer mike
check mike check mike check and I say
and I stand there and wait they stop and
then I'm like do you guys want to answer
and then the woman goes mike check they
all yell repeating do not do not talk to
talk to anyone and I'm like it's a
cult and it's been and it's been
infiltrated and overtaken and that's
exactly that I'm telling you all this
hate your neighbor stuff it's all coming
from the top down it's not coming from
the bottom up and I think people are
starting to Wi you know when I bought a
Baloo boy on my show uh because uh the
Baloo boy gave a speech about how he he
was with somebody from uh the what's
that antifa and he was with some lgbtq
and they were they all came together and
said you're not my enemy we're all
brothers and I was like this is amazing
I never even heard of a bugaloo boy
until that so I bring the guy on my show
he talk we agree on like six out of 10
issues and uh they're anti-war they're
anti- cop they're all this stuff and I
was like wow this is really amazing
they're nothing like I was told and I
and so I never got an onslaught of hate
and U I got smear articles written about
me in New York news week and everything
and it was because that's the only thing
that scares them and so when I started
to figure that out that's when I
realized what the real game is and I'm
not going to hate my neighbor because
we're politically different because they
don't have they're yeah Jimmy D Baloo
boy interview Sparks outrage among
you're a sucker sucker but but you were
not Jimmy you were correct thank you
there there's a video of a bugaloo boy
shaking hands with antifa yeah and uh uh
they were trying to create this division
narrative in the press and claim bugalo
boys were actually white supremacists
and there's the exact opposite even the
ADL said that the bugaloo boys were not
racist but they they the media conflated
proud boys with bugaloo boys bugaloo
boys were response to the proud boys
they wouldn't allow you to be racists
and stuff like that and then when they
started censoring people off uh social
media no longer could the Baloo boys
police their own kind because now you
can't see what those people are saying
if they said something racist in public
they could see it now it went
underground and that's what they wanted
and that's a great way to infiltrate and
again separate and keep everybody
separated in hating each other but also
as for the proud boys uh the media's
lied completely about them as well you
don't have to like the guys I mean they
they you know they're showing up to
protests and whatever you whatever you
think about them but I was in I was in I
think it was Portland and there was a
plan march by a bunch of right-wing
group right-wing group I think it was
Patriot prayer and the proud boys showed
up I am the proud boy plan was we're
going to March to the city that's all
we're going to do but they know antifa
is going to show up and act a fool and
the general idea is well we're allowed
to protest they're not allowed to act a
fool we're going to be a we're going to
do our thing there was a black proud boy
and I think this on my YouTube channel I
think I filmed it and uh as they're
marching down the street the the antifa
guy started yelling the n-word over and
over and over again at him swearing at
him and calling him a variety of racial
slur
and then this
dude he a he was a veteran he was a
black man he just gets super angry and
he starts to walk towards the street to
cross the street to the other side and a
white proud boy walks in front of him
and grabs him and says don't listen to
him man don't let him divide us he's
like you're my brother and he grabs his
hand's like you're my brother man don't
listen to them and I was like what the I
was like the the white and black proud
boy doing that fist grabs Sayang their
brothers while the antifa guy is yelling
the nword you have this video I think
see I'm pretty sure I've seen it too
have been a live stream and it would be
on it's if you're what a moment and and
but also understand there was also a
moment where these antifa activists were
screaming the n-word at ice agents in I
think Seattle as well so don't you think
that H half of the antifa is infiltrated
FBI people just just like you see those
guys dressed up in the khakis and The
Mask those guys are all Feds all of them
all of them if if if if I do have have
the video of it it's going to be a live
stream from youtube.com/ timcast that I
don't think we can find in 10 minutes
cuz these are like 3 Hour 4 hour long
streams but you know what this is all
remnant of of what you're basically
describing you ever seen the movie
Braveheart no I didn't you never seen
Braveheart you guys multiple times okay
gotcha so there's a scene and this is
essentially what you guys are describing
that the Scottish Nobles the Scottish
Lords are sitting on top of a hill
watching what they think is about to be
a battle between Mel Gibson William
Wallace's crew and the other tribe that
they're about to fight against and
they're walking to against each other
they're about to meet in the in the
middle of the battlefield and they're
looking on with such just like amazement
like our two basic biggest thorns on our
side are about to go to battle and they
meet and they come right together in
front of each other and they think
you're about to be a battle and they
[__] they slap hands like this and you
realize holy [__] and in that moment the
the Scottish Nobles and the Lords and
the King they knew they were [__] now
that's essentially the the metaphor for
the establishment once you have a and
BLM and you have the proud boys and
antifa or you have blacks and whites or
Christians and M Muslims all sort of
agreeing being like yeah I'm not so sure
about this and they look towards the
king and the K the king realizes he has
no clothes on that's where you'll see
significant change I don't think anybody
has to agree or high five at all I think
all that has to happen is you're going
to have a group of conservatives you're
going to have a group of bugaloo boys
you're going to have a group of BLM
whatever these groups are and they're
going to have their areas there's going
to be a neighborhood of a bunch of
houses and everyone's there is going to
be like the police aren't helping us
crime is getting out of control we the
riers are not political they're
opportunists they're going to form a
neighborhood watch group then across
that then a few blocks away or whatever
there's a different group with a
different ideology they don't need to
like each other it's that one dude's
going to be like hey I'm going to go I I
know those guys are forming a group
let's go talk to them and see what's up
and then two guys are going to walk up
and it's going to be like look you
believe a lot of weird Lefty stuff that
I don't care for but I got no beef with
you right I just want to make sure my
kids are safe the other guy's going to
say you believe a bunch of weird
right-wing stuff I don't agree with
either but I agree I want my kids to be
safe so we we won't fight with you guys
if you need help let us know we're going
to do our thing you do yours that's
where I think the king gets scared yeah
that's that's it that's the only thing
that scares them and that's why they
keep doing this uh all these culture
wars to keep us distracted and uh I
think you know the believe me the
establishment would be okay with any of
those Republican candidates at that
debate being president including desand
they love it and any of the Democrats
being they just don't want anybody like
Trump or RFK they don't want any body
that's actually outside the system or
who's going to challeng or V don't
forget about him they do not want him
assuming what do you think about I don't
know much about VC but I think they'd be
okay with VC well I think there's a
reason that they all basically attacked
him in the second debate he clearly won
that first debate and we were at that
second debate the knives were out across
the board for this guy yeah I don't I
don't think it I don't think they'd like
him uh VI came on my show and when he
broke down what brought him into the
culture War my my view of V is he's a
very very smart guy he knows how to
control systems and machines he's
playing the political game very very
well but deep within him is a Lust For
Revenge his story do you guys know his
story of how how he got he got into this
he has his big big farmer company
biotech he's ra he makes it worth
billions of dollars whatever putting his
net worth near half a billion dollars
he's probably thinking to himself I got
the dream I did it I I you know from
Ohio immigrant family and he conquered
he rose above and then one day
he gets a message where they're like hey
you know George Floyd died you got to
put up the black Square on your profile
and he's like what are you talking about
he like you got to put up the black
Square he's like okay fine then they
come back to him and they say now you
got to issue a message in support of
George Floyd and he said uh sure I guess
and then he writes a letter saying like
hey this disunity is is is is so harmful
and I'm so it's so unfortunate I hope
this country can learn to heal and come
together then they come to him again
activists are hitting up his company and
they said your message wasn't good
enough and then he breaks and he says F
off like I'm done with this what's going
on then they start attacking his board
members and he starts getting
resignations that I think triggers him
and then he writes the book he woke in
he creates this this uh uh Venture
Capital to oppose Black Rock I I feel
like he thought he did it he did what he
was supposed to do he became successful
and then the the diverse like the the
Dei stuff comes in and they're trying to
use it to destroy him they're telling
him to bend the knee to them as if his
success didn't matter and then people
are resigning he sees the the black Rock
stuff the ESG and he creates a fund to
counter it now now I'm looking at him
and his personality is different when
he's on stage when he's doing politics
he's talking very different and very
yeah cuz he wants to win I I I think his
his attitude is more so a calculating I
hate what these people tried to do to me
and I'm going to win
now okay I hope so
I let me least amount of words that JS
said you don't have to like him I'm
gonna be honest I told this to VI he's
not gonna win you know what I mean but
what's the reason he's not going to win
you can't beat Trump come on the just
that I think the is fantastic I think
you know people talk about um whether
someone is doing something for the right
reasons or the wrong reasons and I'm
like I can't read someone's mind I can
only look at V started a fund to counter
Black Rock and Vanguard and all those
things right he wants to actually
provide funding to companies that oppose
that that's good you don't got to trust
the guy he did a thing I liked people
are like Donald Trump's only doing this
cuz he's he got an ego and he's a
narcissist and I'm like oh okay he's
exposing our our oil fields in Syria
because of his ego I'll take it it's
better than the Liars who are running
the garbage system for their benefit and
then lying to us about it so you don't
have to you don't have to trust him you
have to like him maybe he's in it for
himself maybe he wants to be famous
maybe he's brand building I'll take the
good thing that the good I got three
stories before we wrap up here's one of
them Adidas CEO Kanye West did a mean
anti-semitic remarks this is a reuter
story ad Adidas CEO Bjorn golden
defended Kanye West stating I don't
think he meant that he said and I don't
think he's a bad person regarding y
anti-semitic remarks that led to the
termination of their Yeezy collaboration
gon acknowledged that ye has made
statements that weren't that good and
praised him as one of the most creative
people in the world both in music and
what I will call Street culture didas
maintained its decision to end a
partnership with ye with a spokesperson
confirming uh affirming ending the
partnership was appropriate you think
there's going to be a comeback of Y
coming to Adidas what do you think when
you hear this story I think the whole
thing was a setup I think it was planned
I think is a genius and uh based on my
interview with him the way he was
talking to us before the show is nothing
like his public Persona he was calm
rational completely Lucid having a real
conversation he he was acting like this
he was like what do you think about if I
were to do X Y and Z right you what's
what's going on with Mike Pence how do
they feel about him that's how he was
talking yeah camera turns on yo man I'm
telling you got the guy in these Banks
and I was like what the just happened
and then he had a private jet waiting
for him after the show ended and I don't
know about you guys but I don't know how
you book a private jet in a couple hours
oh wow that's right oh wow that's if you
guys flying private jets you know you
got to Charter these things in advance
they got to get ground Crews when the
ground crew is
notified stop it's a real
headache so I go Southwest yeah I get
you can buy the pre-board so stressed
out you know it's no I got to be honest
it's it's it's flying commercial is a
nightmare they United took me off of my
first class ticket and rebooked me
without telling me at 4 in the morning
onto a uh a seat all the way in the back
economy minus whatever it's called that
that thing where you're not allow to
have a carry on and I was like bro I
paid $1,000 for this flight cuz we had
to we had to you know we're going to
this trip and I was coming home and then
they were like too bad take the flight
or stay and I'm like what am I supposed
to do but anyway so yeah so so you were
saying Tim about so so he's on the I'm
curious of where the setup is cu if he's
on camera off camera speaking one
certain way all of a sudden camera's on
like almost some MK
Ultra and then and then I I get the
point that you making like and Pat knows
this like trying to get a freaking it's
a system they got to get people's names
they got to pre-board pre-check you and
do all that stuff so you're saying like
set up in what sense so uh Shane Cashman
one of our writers is a huge yay fan and
he talks he wrote this article about how
yay has these periods where he shocks
the world in an offensive way and then
leaves for a little bit then has a major
comeback it's like a PR strategy or
something that effect he comes out and
he says all these things he agrees to
come on our show before the show while
we're talking totally lucid and calm he
says I have no reason to be on a show
like this and I said you're completely
right I was like you don't why are you
here like you don't get more famous if
you want to come come on my show I
appreciate it and he's like well these
guys told me I should do it but he's
like what I'm really interested in is
you telling me how I become president
and I said ballot harvesting he was like
ballot harvesting I'm like I said you
want to know how the Democrats won they
don't win by by convincing people they
win by getting more votes and you get
more votes if your ballot harvesting he
goes ballot harvesting he writes it down
he goes I got what I need
shut up not kidding show starts and all
of a sudden he goes from this calm Lucid
guy to Y man I'm going to get a PJ if
you keep talking like that and then he
gets up and he walks out and I'm like is
he he's smiling he goes downstairs he
thanks everybody shakes hands he tells
my writer you want to come with me back
to LA and and and work with on some
stuff plane was waiting for him I I I
called our our charter company and I
said did you give him like did you give
him a plane like what happened and they
were like no no no no and I'm like
Frederick Municipal has a private jet I
think like a gulf stream or something
waiting for yay and I'm he can leave I'm
not I'm not mad about that but how did
he get a PJ in an hour and she and my my
broker but the charter lady she's like
that's not possible wow so the plane
knew the yes and then people are like
why would he do that because he got the
front page of every newspaper by walking
out on the show I see that if he doesn't
interview on like okay timcast IRL is a
big show I get it we we we typically
have like some of the highest live
numbers I think we're the biggest live
show consistently every night on YouTube
but we're no I don't beat you you're
sure I don't beat you you don't beat us
I'm kidding oh I don't know I'm kidding
but but like we're not the biggest show
in the world or anything like that you
know in terms of podcast we do well so
people are like why would he Co on your
show and I'm like doing an interview
with me gets him nothing he does the
interview there are some clips people
roll their eyes storming off the
interview is hot press for all the
tabloids big time that was your
important question is what colors your
PJ Jimmy his pajamas or his private J
everybody's wondering like PJ why was he
is his PJ and didn't he just trademark
yesterday he trademarked 25 names uh for
use ye WS Kanye did that which is sounds
like yees and Jew I don't know what he's
did you see that trademark use wow but I
want I want to get some context too
because uh I'm you guys have fown on
private jets right yeah well Jimmy
multiple times obviously but what people
need to understand is it it's it's not
as it people assume you have to have a
multi-million dollar jet it's not some
private jets only cost a couple hundred
grand no no joke if you if you look up
on these websites you can find a lot of
the Jets that they Charter and they fly
are from 1980 and they're like $200,000
to buy I'm not saying people have 200
Grand but it's not $10 million like you
see these CEOs on Gulf streams
chartering a private jet can be $6,000
$8,000 if you've got eight or8 to 12
people and you're trying to fly last
minute for work it could actually be
cheaper than flying commercial if you're
if you're working in a corporation what
kind of plane is this is this the kind
of plane that's crashed to 8,000 tur
turbo props should you want to go Tim
Tim back to your master plan from Kanye
okay that was his master plan for your
show I I mean this is all speculation
but it seems pretty accurate I I just
from your opinion because you've you did
this on your show but it was part of a
bigger master plan what's his overall
master plan to get in the headlines all
right so one can argue all right I'm
going to run up on stage and I'm going
to tell Taylor Swift that it should have
been Beyonce all right cool you know mge
doesn't care about black people Mike
Myers George okay awesome hey I'm gonna
marry Kim K I'm gonna get all I'm gonna
all the women of the world are gonna my
next album okay amazing all right I'm
gonna team up with J Jay-Z Watch the
Throne now Mary Kim K wasn't a stunt he
loved that woman obviously but there was
some go involved there then all right
I'm going to go see U uh Donald Trump
with Jim Brown I'm gonna do all that
walk me through Let Me Go full Pro
Hitler
anti-jew death Con 3 walk me through the
marketing strategy for that you I mean I
can only speculate but he's a
billionaire he's done it not anymore
yeah but what does it really mean to be
a billionaire I like if you're talking
about paper value and like shoe deals
are worth a couple hundred million
dollars the dude wants for nothing I I
you look at some of these people they
get to that point where they're bored I
had a buddy of mine became a millionaire
at 16 I didn't meet him when we were 16
I met him when we were in the late 20s
and he told me that for most people es
the at least that he knows especially in
the tech sector they have an existential
crisis once they get to that level of
money so for him he's like this young
guy he comes up with this idea they
start building this thing and then all
of a sudden he's got millions of dollars
and he's sitting there staring at the
wall like what do I do all my friends
are at work I'm not I don't have to do
anything now I I sold out there's no
company anymore I don't need anything
and it was like a switch flip where they
he had an existential crisis and he says
a bunch of my friends experienced this
so you look at someone like yay and I'm
like he's bored he's bored and it's
funny and there's nothing you can do
about it cuz he's more powerful than you
it makes him laugh he wants to see
what'll happen he wants to challenge
preconceived notions he wants to break
people out of what he perceives as the
Matrix he made a point that a lot of
people praised when he said that he
loved Hitler and people were shocked by
it and I think the point he was trying
to make was as a Christian he loves
everyone even the most evil people he
wants salvation for them but he also
knows that by saying something so
shocking you would freak out and he's
trying to prove that point that you
don't love people and I'm like I can
understand why nobody likes Hitler dude
are you crazy but he's trying to make a
point I could only speculate he wants to
shock you it's punk rock I mean I'm not
saying it's a good thing but what was it
Sid Vicious wor a swastika it's it's
like why did he do that Jimmy why are
you smiling you got this big smile Jimmy
knows what's going Jimmy's like listen
I've been a billionaire since years old
Jimmy is there anything you like to say
about the Jews right now well I remember
when this happened the my friend called
me goes hey hey did you hear the Jews
cancel Kanye and I was like did they
catch him shipping arms to Nazis in
Ukraine and they said no he just said
some stuff and I'm like oh that's bad
too yeah simp did the Jews cancel Kanye
or did he actually cancel himself
because it sounds like this was part
of's uncancelled but
yeah he's back okay yeah but and Tim you
made a point earlier like if he got
cancelled for saying those words the
Canadian Parliament had an actual Nazi
on the godamn FL they should have
cancelled the Canadian shut down Canada
are you freaking kidding me and I get it
words hurt but for that moment to go
down and then what they do they just
fire the the speaker of the house just
steps down you had a a Nazi that
actually killed Jews that that is absurd
a Hitler Nazi a Hitler Nazi not a
regular like the original the
OG old school not that last story here
before we wrap just could you imagine
being that Nazi
he's getting a standing waving to
everybody he's like this is the best day
of my life but imagine what think if you
only know what I did to my God oh my God
what's the story Pat yeah so let's wrap
this up with Putin so Putin a story
comes out um about next Generation
nuclear weapon he says Russia's mission
is to create a new world and then the
speech comes out if you got the clip R
to just play the clip here's what he
says on this video
uh goad and play there probably a
question hanging in the air about what
happened to the company's management and
so on but we know about the plane
crash the head of the investigative
Committee reported to me just the other
day that fragments of hand grenades were
found in the bodies of those killed in
the crash there was no external impact
on the airplane this is an established
fact the result of the examination
conducted by the investigative Committee
of the the Russian
Federation but the investigation is not
completed yes unfortunately the presence
of alcohol or drugs in the blood of the
Dead the examination was not conducted
although we know that after the famous
events in the company in St Petersburg
the FSB found not only 10 billion in
cash but also 5 kilog of cocaine but I
repeat once again in my opinion
such an examination should have been
carried out a video I sent you is this a
video I sent you uh this oh I'm sorry
that might be talking
pran I was going to say the cocaine that
means it's CIA right I was like pran so
that means he basically was saying is
though they there was a Grenade on the
plane but Po's like yeah but there was
cocaine too like who gives the damn
people on Cain that's not the video I
wanted him to play I want him to play
this video okay play this video
Rob
[Music]
Sweeten
wow not a single enemy a chance of
survival not a single enemy do you think
he means it yep I actually think there's
a strong possibility he he begins using
nuclear weapons over Ukraine the uh
understand nuclear weapon does not mean
ICBM it could be uh nuclear artillery it
could be lower yield 100 kiloton bombs
but uh on the
battlefield uh uh Putin has already
stated the use of depleted uranium
rounds coming from the UK uh constitutes
the use of nuclear weapons and thus you
know their actions are warranted if it
came to the point where Putin was losing
and I think if you look at the battle
map he secured the region he wanted to
secure if he really wanted Poland oh
yeah he'd start using Tech nuclear
artillery and then no one there there
was actually a Polish NPI said there
will not be mutually Shir destruction
because no one in their right mind would
sacrifice New York over I forgot what
city he said like a small town in Poland
right that if if Putin actually did nuke
a NATO country there's not going to be
nuclear war the West will not retaliate
and if that is true and coming from a
NATO Nation I mean if you pull up the
quote it's probably it's more specific I
forgot what polish city they said I do
not see a scenario in which the West
fires nuclear weapons at Russia if
Russia uses nuclear weapons in Eastern
Europe well I just think that the
world's terrorist is the United States
military and NATO and if you look around
the globe there's over 800 military
bases for United States and NATO and
they're building more and more we've
surr rounded China and uh Russia and the
aggressors is obviously nato in the
United States and we're the only country
that's ever been proven to use nuclear
weapons and the people who run our
military-industrial complex are
bloodthirsty Maniacs who have killed
millions of people over the last two
decades and displaced millions and
millions more for uh economic lust and
that's what this is that's what the
Ukraine war is about that's what China
is about that's what Syria was about
Libya Iraq Afghanistan it's all about an
upward transfer of wealth from the tax
base to uh the military-industrial
complex and the International Security
State and then of course fossil fuel
companies that's what this is about that
that's why we're selling more liquefied
natural gas right now that's why we blew
up that pipeline that's what this is all
about and that's what and Russia just
doesn't want Ukraine to be put into NATO
that's the only demand and they said go
pound s we're not going to give you that
again because we want you to invade
Ukraine we want this war this is how we
make money and this is how all Empires
End by the way and this is how we're
ending we're starving our own people at
home while we uh ex do these military
inventionist over overseas and we're not
stopping and this is what all Matt Gates
is about it it was about we got to stop
this and you see what's happening he's
going to be I bet there's going to be
criminal charges against him don't you
think they're of course of course this
is why men keep thinking about the uh
Roman Empire yep
big Tik Tok yeah but uh uh it's funny
because these women are all like why are
men thinking about the Roman Empire It's
like because we are witnessing we are
witnessing it you know yeah and it's
it's funny though that none of this H
like this was supposed to be happening
under Trump that's exactly and so they
said that Trump was he was the guy who's
alienating all our friends and the
people don't respect us the exact
opposite happened uh Biden comes into
power and now there are all these other
countries joining together coalescing in
economic power centers like bricks to
oppose the United States that was not
there before and we're pushing China and
Russia together which is the last thing
we were supposed to want they don't care
and we've always were afraid of Germany
coming Germany with their uh with their
engineering and their Capital coming
together with Russia's Manpower and
their natural resources and we've been
worried about that for decades and
that's what was happening with the stre
pipeline and that's what this is all
about and you know uh when Trump got
elected in 2016 I that wasn't just
happening in America that was also
brexit happened people were starting to
revolt against the establishment and
that's why they got to do this National
Security State they got to put everybody
under surveillance and take away your
freedom of speech and they got to divide
everybody because it's not just in the
United States people around the world
are waking up and getting sick of the
establishment so we I hopefully there'll
be a worldwide Revolution to happen soon
well for what it's word this was an
insane podcast we talked about a bunch
of different things appreciate you guys
for coming out both of you here's what
we learned we learned today okay that
Tim P's favorite Vault flavor is black
cherry it's good it is okay although you
did try the Cucumber mint yesterday and
you know I don't like cucumber or mint
that's it's still good yeah but he also
like the poow that's coming soon but
Matt Gates yes it is like I had four of
these already I'm feeling yeah Matt had
like four them himself locks your brain
yeah so by the way indirectly go order a
case a vault and try it for yourself
unleash the inner genius Rob let's put
the link do that it's on Amazon you can
get the different flavors on Amazon
aside from that uh Jimmy do you have
anything that's going on right now you
want the audience going yeah I'm going
to be doing a show tonight in uh boa Ron
at the blackbox theater sick yeah
tomorrow night I'll be at the Improv in
Orlando and next week I'll be at the
House of Blues in Houston and another
place in Dallas so go to Jimmy door.com
and click on tour and we'll see you at a
live show fantastic Tim anything on your
end oh well we just wrapped Our Big Show
last night great show other than that
we're going to go home I I really
appreciate you coming down but people
can just check out our work at
timcast.net and for some of you guys
that want to get a discounted private
jet you can email them as well PJ it's
PJ PJ and can I can I say my my last one
too cuz I uh Tampa Improv October 18th
Jimmy was just there you were just there
at the Tampa Improv it was amazing it's
a great Club the guy who runs it I love
and I'll be there October 18th go to um
Vincent oan on my Instagram the ticket
link is in my bio fantastic gang have a
great weekend everybody take care bye
bye bye
bye